hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
although I've done over 700 episodes of
this show at this point and on some
level all of these conversations are
special I would say that this one is
uniquely special and it's special
because my guest today is somebody who
although we had never met in person
until the date of this podcast
nonetheless has greatly inspired and
influenced my endurance career he's
somebody who has kind of mentored me
from afar in ways almost beyond my
ability to calculate his name is Gordo
Byrne Gordo is a guy who kind of took
The Road Less Traveled he's a former
private Equity investment banker who
ended up transforming himself into an
elite Ultra endurance athlete as well as
a student of Elite Performance a veteran
endurance coach a co-author with Joe
Friel of the endurance Bible entitled
going long and mostly a devoted family
man and one of the things that makes
Gordo more aspirational versus
inspirational is that his athletic
Journey this guy who started out as an
obese Finance guy and turned himself
into an elite athlete really began with
a simple walk that walk turned into a
jog that jog turned into a run and
thereafter what set in was this
obsession with Elite endurance
performance that culminated in seven sub
nine hour Ironmans including an 829 for
second place at Iron Man Canada and also
being crowned Ultraman world champion in
2002 a result at my very favorite race
that captured my Fascination and really
motivated in so many ways my own
Ultraman dreams and performances in
addition to some shared DNA in both our
backstories as well as our life
philosophies
one of the reasons Gordo was able to so
profoundly impact me back in the mid to
late 2000s is that he was a willing and
an early adopter of sharing his
experience on the internet as a web 1.0
blogger as well as an early podcaster
and it's a tradition that he continues
today on Twitter at field of burn and
this conversation was everything I hoped
it would be we discuss leveraging pain
to catalyze a life change the dangers of
chasing Elite Performance we talk about
what endurance teaches us about life
we discussed the importance of creating
what he calls a 1 000 day plan and how
success is really built upon small steps
undertaken with ruthless consistency our
mutual friend Jonas colting the Swedish
Superstar multiple Ultraman and otello
Champion calls Gordo quote Tony Robbins
in a speedo and I agree with that and
I'm pretty sure after listening to this
one you will too final note I recorded
this podcast old school during my recent
visit to Boulder just two mics and
Gordo's home no cameras so although this
one is a rare Audio Only throwback
episode on some level it's also very
much well worth your full attention so
with that please hit that subscribe
button and enjoy this dive into the pain
cave with the singular Gordo burn
super nice to be here with you we're
going old school Audio Only me with my
traveling recording suitcase at your
home today I've been wanting to meet you
forever I just tweeted out a little bit
ago that uh
you have been like this North Star or
compass in my life dating back I think
to about 2007 when I was first getting
interested in Fitness endurance
Triathlon Etc and you were like this OG
blogger going all the way back to like
web 1.0 you know on forums and stuff
like that
um one of the few you know kind of
really cogent voices out there uh
talking about how to do this thing
correctly and without us ever having met
prior to today you've had just a
tremendous influence on my life so you
know just publicly I wanted to thank you
for that guidance and that mentorship
from afar and so I'm just thrilled to be
able to talk to you today it's great to
make the connection I mean it
this is a very special uh opportunity
for me as a triathlete I had a lot of
success
but the one thing I wanted to do
and I was never able to do it was the
big room speech what does that mean you
know at first I was like some of your
tweets are cryptic they're like Zen
cohens I'm like trying to decode them
I'm like what is the big speech so
I got really fit
in 2004 really fit it's fit as anybody
and
I I raced Ironman Canada and I had a
flat tire and it came up a little bit
short
and I finished second and it was great
it was a really really good experience
and the night before
the race I wrote my victory speech
and I never got a chance to deliver it
and it was a uh it's actually something
I got out of the artist's way Julia
Cameron you know just make it happen
and one of the weirdest things about
that whole summer
is I actually dreamed my finishing time
a month before the race like down to the
minute wow and the whole I mean I got I
got I'm tingling because it's all coming
back but it was just such a special
block
from March
to August of that year we uh we rode
Across America my friend and
I and and then I trained under Dave
Scott
with his team world is what he called it
it was like me Simon Lessing Michael
Lovato
and all these really fit women
in skimpy shorts and sports bras after
I'd been living in a trailer for a
couple of months going across the U.S it
was just it was an amazing opportunity
for me and I came out a came out of that
whole experience just feeling just in
the best shape of my life right and it
was kind of you know when you have that
you have that great build you have that
opportunity and it all kind of comes
together on the day and the obviously
the flat is kind of something you
remember but so much went right that
year that day and so it was just a
really special experience but I never
got to deliver the speech I wrote it for
my for my column for x-rays who I wrote
for at the time but I never really got
to reach the people and say the things
so I got some things that maybe we get
into that I've been kind of holding on
to for maybe 18 years right and well I'm
out I'm giving you the platform we'll
let it we'll let it like kind of seep
out over the course of of you telling
the story but what are some of the
general tenets of that speech what are
the principles so I you know the most
important thing is really
you know I got a copy of Finding Ultra
on my desk here beside us
and I think a lot of people read that
and it's just such an amazing story so
great and and so honest
and and in that people would say well
you know yeah Rich did all these amazing
things but you know you know he was a
great athlete to walk on at Stanford and
stuff and and um and I I really wanted
to tell everybody and that
you know we all have these talents in us
that we have no idea about and we have
these paths in our lives that we can
take at any time
that we really we never get to see
because we never take them and so I was
okay in the book you have your bike
crashed and Julie comes to you and she's
um
you know hey is is it it if this was it
you know yes or no I mean are you cool
with that and and so I'm I'm in Hong
Kong
and it's uh 2000 and just got divorced
and I'm in I'm I'm at the top of the
Heap I'm a partner in a private Equity
Firm
I'm making a lot of money but I'm alone
you know it's just just me and my maid
in the house and it's a beautiful house
it's a townhouse Persian rugs
art on the wall deal everything
everything
and we just raised a huge fund
and the next 10 years are like mapped
out for me I'm gonna be a partner gonna
make a lot of money my boss is great my
partners are great they let me do
whatever I want I had that kind of
support you talk about I'm secure in the
organization and and there's just
nothing
I'm like you know if I spend the next 10
years doing this I will have wasted
my 30s it would have been a complete
waste it's like that moment yeah
and so I I'm like I got to make a change
yeah that Rubicon moment I mean I'm I'm
getting Goosebumps now hearing this I
mean there's a lot of shared DNA here I
mean the facts of your life and
experience are are different from mine
in in certain qualitative ways but
there's a lot of overlap here you wrote
my book and uh so great yeah it's just
you know the fact that you had all of
that makes it all the harder to walk
away right like everybody would claim
your you know you're you're being
ludicrous to consider an alternative
path when you're reaping the benefits
that Society Smiles upon my family
begged me not to do it like they're like
you're nuts and I was just like oh what
was the
I want to like double click and drill
down on that moment because I think you
know to your point of all of us sitting
atop mountains of untapped potential
that were completely oblivious to I
think we're all visited with different
versions of those moments in our life
but it requires a certain either a pain
point or a presence of mind to recognize
them and then even further to take any
kind of action upon that pain Point yeah
divorce you know it was that that was a
that was the moment
where everything I thought I was going
to do with my life got yanked
and I had the plan
I was gonna ultimately you know the
whole private Equity thing swing it into
the Bay Area get to Cali I mean I had
The Five-Year Plan and it was all going
to come together and
the wedding or the marriage was just
like a year right it was a short-lived
marriage it's very similar to the story
and
and you know but likewise how you closed
out that chapter where you said you know
what the benefit of time
I felt my own role I mean I I was I
created that situation because all I
wanted to do was work or ride my bike
you know and recognizing that and owning
it is is the only way to free yourself
from whatever complicated emotions you
have about it yeah and and you know
write something about it and publish it
I mean my blog my writing has been
therapeutic for well since my teens I've
been writing a lot
and when I when I write when I publish
it just goes I mean sometimes people
come to me about my blogs and tell or
and but they'll just come to me about a
personal episode in my life and I'm kind
of thinking how do you know that and and
they're like well I read it a year and a
half ago and it just leaves me when I
publish it it's really good it's a great
way for me to deal with stuff right well
you've been writing online for like 17
years or something a long time
right you could and still you can
unearth those archives like Gordo's
world or whatever the original you know
sort of website was and I got a little
public and I got a hard drive that's got
all the other stuff too I mean it's just
sitting there and I read it and it's
neat because it makes sense but you know
it's gone like like I'm I'm reliving it
in a sense when I go back and read my
Diaries yeah well this is a little bit
of a tangent we'll get back to the The
Narrative but yes you are you know
prolific and how often you post it's
very much I don't know if this has
influenced you but it feels to me very
much like a page out of the Seth Godin
book like he writes a blog post every
single day some of them are long but
most of them are are pretty short and
yours you know as I said earlier are
kind of like they're puzzles on some
level like they are Zen cohens like
you'll have just like seven lines like
really the economy of language you know
like like and then I'll spend the day
like trying to decipher exactly you know
what you mean and then you made a choice
to kind of disappear from the internet
for a while about a decade yeah you
resurfaced recently and we can get into
later you know the reasons behind that
but that's how we ended up reconnecting
like you you followed me and I was like
and then I realized I wasn't following
you and I was like wait I know that I
was following Gordo I dm'd you and I was
like I apologize I thought he's like no
I you deleted your account now you're
back with a vengeance posting on Twitter
you're sort of using Twitter as a micro
blogging platform yeah posting these
threads that get you know a lot of
Engagement
yeah and the well let's just talk a bit
about social media it's been great and
and I think it's been great because I'm
doing it with intent and I and I know
why I'm there and the and I'm limiting
how I'm doing it
so about say probably about two years
ago the pandemic was really hard The
Homeschool and just the nature of being
locked down and in the house all the
time I don't do too well with that and
there's a lot of static
and drama
on Facebook
and I find Instagram creates all this
memetic desire in me for stuff it gets
me wanting to take my life somewhere
that I don't want to go but I'm
powerless against images and video
that's why I mainly read books I'm very
prone to suggestion so movies video
pictures I mean they just control me
yeah so those platforms are really tough
for me Twitter is more a reading type
platform so I can kind of tailor it a
bit more and hand a little bit more so I
was just like you know what
I'm going to take a 30-day break from
everything and I got to the end of 30
days and I'm like I'm just going to Nuke
it nuke to everything and started fresh
now with Twitter why I wanted to start
fresh
was I felt that my life had changed from
when I was in the lead athlete and so
the the people in that group
knew me in in one aspect of my life and
I was like you know what I just want to
start small with people that I can
relate to and relate to me and I really
want to just build this community and
get some Connection in my life and it's
been it's been really good for that
making me feel connected
and then the other thing the other I'm
pretty niched down with my life exercise
physiology training trying to be fit in
middle age and so I'm able to follow
people that are world-class experts at
helping me go where I want to go and
they'll answer my questions and engage
with me and I just I that's just so nuts
that I can ask some guy in Helsinki
about human physiology and he'll he'll
answer right and and or
there's a high school coach in Texas
that's teaching me how to get my
daughter to jump higher so her starts
her quicker in swimming and they're all
just there and you and you can you just
put something out there and they'll like
answer you within 24 hours and and
I think it's uh if you use it with
intent it can be a very powerful tool
for learning mindful curation I was we
were chatting before the podcast and I
was saying that I probably follow too
many people and a you know a culling is
probably an order for me right now uh
but for some reason the algorithm when I
open up that app the first time each day
it's basically posts from you from Alan
cousins from Steve Magnus and from Brad
stolberg yeah so that's like my initial
hit every time which is positive and
always kind of directional you know in a
positive way and so it really is about
like how you're managing it and that is
you know your own responsibility it is
and and that's
in any situation I I one of the things I
ask myself is you know it's good well
there's two things it's like what's my
role here and what am I trying to what's
my purpose
um and and I think when we run into
situations where we feel like we're
getting a bit
stressed out we've lost track of those
two things
um the role and and sort of what we're
trying to get out of it yeah well let's
take it back to the kind of life story
aspect of this I mean we jumped right to
Hong Kong but let's go away let's go
let's go way back I mean you grew up in
Vancouver right but were you an athlete
as a kid no not at all so I'm reading
reading about you setting Summer League
records and that's what my kids do now
they set Summer League records but I
didn't have that childhood my my memory
if I'm thinking about myself in
elementary school I'm kind of chubby
I played badminton you know I ate Donuts
right I I was not a I was not an athlete
didn't think of myself as an athlete
until Ultraman which we'll get to in
time
and um just really actually I have this
memory of kindergarten
or something when I was like that age
that five or six and I got some sort of
report card and they told me that on in
the report card it said gross motor
deficient and I didn't even know what
that meant and and I and I asked I can't
believe you remember that well it was
deficient you know and gross it sounded
like so big like such a big deal and um
it just meant I was really awkward you
know it didn't wasn't very coordinated
and I was like oh it's deficient and
then we lived in Boston for a couple
years my dad was going to school and um
they tried to I don't even remember
hockey but they tried to get me to play
hockey and I couldn't like I couldn't
skate and and so then they put me in net
and you know tried well maybe we can
make them a goalie you can just stand
there but I couldn't do that either so
then they just had to we just had to
stop
and so I was a kid that didn't have any
real athletic stuff and then I was
always the youngest in the year and I I
grew kind of normally but everybody was
always bigger than me and that that
worked itself out by the end of high
school so my my final year of I was 17
when I graduated and I was just starting
to get an inkling of kind of my physical
capacity and then um yeah and didn't
play any real
I played football in high school and uh
figured that out by the end
and then in University I I was not a
walk-on at a national class you go to
school in Montreal exactly which was
great yeah I loved it I would have
stayed there if I could have if worked
in French but I'm an English speaker
right so where does the finance thing
come in then so the finance is my degree
so I I gotta do it oh well let's go way
back so I'm a kid not really good at
anything but I'm very good at math
and
um and then I I'm good at math I'm good
at chemistry anything that's kind of
formula driven where you can kind of if
it's black and white I'm really good at
it as a kid
so my dad was my dad was in finance and
I was like well you know maybe I'll
track into something similar to him so I
go to Mcgill and do my finance degree
there do some economics as well
the economics degree I mean other than
intro to economics the economics degree
was not particularly useful as it turned
out when I went out in the real world
but the business degree in the finance
side was pretty useful
and I get an opportunity
to do a two-month uh yeah kind of like
internship over in London
and I didn't know it but the desk they
gave me the the guy that was sitting
there before me it had a nervous
breakdown because he was working so hard
wow so they so I wrote shadowing
this is your life I roll it kind of like
a dick in dickensian kind of way well
yeah but you I mean you know the life
and uh I'm just really into it I'm I'm
enjoying it and uh I the guy that works
right beside me
a guy called Alan hate he's he's really
good at his job
and we hit it off and he kind of takes
me under his wing and he teaches me
everything and because I'm good at uh
the Excel and the math and and all that
and and the accounting I'm able to learn
pretty quick and so there's six Partners
in our group and me and Alan and we
we just do a lot of case studies and
this is 1990 in London I think interest
rates were like 15 and we're doing
leveraged buyouts and stuff and it's
really difficult the first year but
interest rates start coming down
and everybody's been beat up there's
been a recession and stuff and so all of
a sudden we start doing deals and I just
get an opportunity to do a ton of work
for three years and I end up I'm in
London for four years
and in that period I was thinking going
off to business school even applied but
then I realized I'd just be asking for
my old job back and so I decided to stay
with the firm
and they set up a new operation in Hong
Kong I knew everybody in Europe they're
like you know I have no ties and they're
like why don't you go out to Asia yeah
and we'll promote you
and so I'm so what would I be 25 years
old and I'm a partner in a private
Equity Firm heading off to a new region
it was great right and so during your
tenure in London what was this state of
your Fitness you have that famous photo
of you that kind of percolates up in the
internet that I remember seeing at the
very beginning of of my journey of you I
think you're on a boat yeah you got your
shirt off yeah uh that goes back to
Gordo World days of you blogging and not
looking so fit uh not like hugely obese
you look like a banker you know and I
was like that is me like I I just so
identified with that image of you at
that time so there's another picture
that I wish I had saved because it was a
picture of me at Peak weight at an
office function and I had these big
white because you know you're kind of
pale when you're in the UK and I had
these big white jowls so I'm 24.
we're jowls and I'm so pale and and I'm
drunk and I'm having a blast and I wish
I had saved that one but it's gone so
all I got is like front of the boat like
uh kind of hairy kind of pale yeah well
when you're in that state you don't
you're not like keen on having your
picture taken too often right so it's
like the one of me and Finding Ultra
like I I got way heavier than that I
just couldn't find any photos of it so
especially without my shirt on you know
so I found them I ran them through the
shredder the so yeah let's talk about
that that one moment I decided
and I and I got and I have no idea why I
decided to go for a walk
that was it I just decided to go for a
walk
and I
and because you had some kind of base
level discussed with your physical
condition at the time or what was the
inspiration for that be sick of sickness
it's the only cure you know
and I I I'm just you know so all right
let's dial it back maybe I'm 23 24. I
just decided to go for a walk I was like
you know what I'm gonna go for a walk
and then we decide well maybe we could
walk to the pub
or maybe we could walk between pubs we'd
go out to the country so I'm still
living the same life right not changing
my eating still drinking all the time
very much that kind of Banker lifestyle
but let me throw in some walking we just
start by walking
and there was this whatever it was there
was this uh drive or this desire in me
to be just healthier be better and um
and then I start bike commuting in
London and and then I find out I'm going
to get promoted I'm like well I should
probably clean up my act a bit because
everybody dressed fancy in Hong Kong the
Brits are pretty well I don't know what
it's like now but back then it was
pretty you didn't really have to look
too sharp
and uh I mean some people did
but you know they're they're okay with
kind of however however I looked we'd
wear a tie but it wasn't like all fancy
whereas out in Hong Kong everybody's
wearing
yeah it's like tailored suits and it's
more New York the look or if you think
back to New York and um in the early 90s
and stuff before we all kind of went
casual
so I'm like all right gotta turn it
around and uh so I roll out to uh I'm
still not I'm still heavy
um but I'm starting to get starting to
get a bit of Fitness I haven't lost
really lost any weight I roll out to
Hong Kong
and don't know anybody get back into
lifting weights and um start lifting
weights again start hiking uh hiking
leads to maybe a little bit of jogging
jog the downs
and then I decide to climb
Kilimanjaro
out of the blue where did that come from
I have no idea I I was probably I you
know I always loved reading climbing
books and I had some friends
that before there was ever these really
nice indoor climbing gyms
the YWCA and Kowloon in Hong Kong took a
squash court and they just drilled holds
into the walls and we used to go over
there and um climb and then we'd run
after work
so like Monday Wednesday Friday say you
do the squash court thing
Tuesday Thursday Saturday you do a run
on Tuesday Thursday and then you go for
a long hike on Saturday so the week
that's kind of what the week looked like
and it was a group of guys and they were
all Ultra Runners but I wasn't at their
level so I could do the shorter stuff
with them and then kind of hike on my
own on the weekends but over time you
know I I build it up and and I start
getting more uh fit
and then when I do these little trips I
do day trips in Asia so um semaru is a
volcano in Indonesia
and I I just flew in
climbed it in a long weekend I was back
at my desk on Tuesday uh kind of blue
Borneo
uh near Kota kinablu that's the airport
you fly into I think it's 4 100 meters
these are Big you know big kind of days
right but it's not not too not technical
it's just hiking and I noticed that the
the mountaineering I just love it
and one of the things
about anybody that gets into ultra
distance is that we
experience exercise differently than
many people
so my internal experience of exercise
something is happening in my
neurochemistry which is different than
the average person so talk about that a
little bit more I get high
I mean that's the only way to describe
it I'm I'm buying the kombucha in uh
in Whole Foods this morning check out
guy
says hey man you look really
really happy you look really good and I
was like well I I spent the whole
morning exercising
and and it just gives off a Vibe and and
it's uh
you know it's and and I felt so this
feeling it's coming to me in the mid 90s
in my 20s
and it builds right but what's so cool
is that it is this really
slow percolating progression that begins
with a walk right and then years later
it's like okay I'm gonna hike this
mountain yeah but this is over
quite an extended period of time yeah so
you're trying to wrestle with like what
is my relationship to physical activity
and my body and the direction of my life
yeah so how'd I end up in Triathlon so
I'm married I'm married for one year
okay
uh my wife goes and sees a fortune
teller
the fortune teller says uh your
husband's gonna die in the mountains
so she comes home she says hey
fortune teller told me you were going to
die in the mountains
and I'm like oh that's kind of
unfortunate because I I gotta
expedition to climb Denali coming up
okay
and I I don't know if the Denali thing
was it might have no it was anyhow so
she gets the
she gets that and so I'm like you know
what and it's like you know that with
mountaineering it's like good great debt
that says your general progression and I
was like okay well you know there's
probably a chance because I was doing
some business stuff and they wanted to
do a life insurance policy and I
answered the questionnaire
honestly right and they tripled my
premium premium yeah and I'm like I'm in
good health and at this stage I'm not
even 30 years old and they're like sorry
that's that's just what it says and so
it's these things so I was like you know
what I'll just let it go and so I'm on
this bulletin board before we had all
this internet stuff and everybody's
talking about this thing called IMC and
I've got no idea what IMC is and so I
researched I find out it's Iron Man
Canada
so I I know I can do a 13-hour Summit
day and but I I don't know how to swim
and I don't have a bike in Hong Kong but
it's just I'm like you know what I'll
figure it out so I uh I sign up and this
is back where you could just sign up so
right but it's not like your story was
six months to Ultraman or whatever it
was this was one year to an Iron Man and
this would have been
I was just about to turn 30.
and I start going to Masters
and I get myself a triathlon bike
and uh Troy Jacobson
and Troy Jacobson is my first coach and
the piece of paper would roll off the
fax machine every Sunday or Monday or
whatever this is your plan that was back
then it just the piece of paper comes
out and that's what you're doing that
week
and he gets me through my first Iron Man
but on the way you know I know nothing
and so I'm and did this supplant the
Denali Expedition no I got I got that no
you went and did it I I did it it didn't
die but that was marriage doesn't work
out but you know at least you you
summited Denali well so so in that first
Iron Man year that's my marriage year
that's the the so the so
and and we'll get to an interesting
story I want to talk about the race
there's something similar to your
experience
so though so we we so I'm I'm training I
I get the bike but uh there's all this
stuff with Triathlon that I that kind of
scare me like you know the Open Water I
you know I got no background with
swimming and oh the first race I did I
was second to last out of the water the
last guy was 80 and it was me and so
that it was a it was a Sprint try and I
had stapled my race number like through
my bike Jersey to my run Jersey or
something and I'm all like pinned up and
everything and so I get out second to
last and obviously I'm passing people
the whole day and so I have a really
good experience I mean being a slow
swimmer in triathlons not a not a
problem I mean it'd be much tougher for
you because then you have the
encouragement of like passing people but
moving forward you're a good swimmer
then you just end up getting past for
the rest of the race and that was
actually I think that's part of why I
was able to learn so quickly because I
would move through most the field and be
able to see what's really going on it
was really helpful to me as a coach
but so one of my first triathlons Escape
from Alcatraz so I signed up for that
because I figure if you can jump off a
boat in the middle of the harbor and get
to shore
Lake Okanagan in Penticton for Ironman
Canada you're going to be good like so
so I'm kind of you overload you just
overload the system
and that race goes that race goes pretty
well I mean there was some
breaststroking and a little bit of
floating on my back in the harbor
because I I had a tendency to go out too
fast and it is even though it's not a
long swim it's a scary swim you're way
out in the middle there when you're like
halfway and the current starts to go
back out towards the bridge it's uh
you're like I'm in a shipping Lane right
now I I love that race I did so I've
done that race unfit super fit I've done
the rock and roll version or whatever it
was the kind of fancy one and then I did
the original where you swim into Aquatic
Park it's I it's just such an amazing
venue uh to to race it's just that
pretty technical for a triathlon yeah it
was it's just kind of up and down
um a lot of do that part where you run
on the sand and then you run up that
that ladder the the staircase from the
beach yeah sand ladder I had a
one year I had a mustache and so there's
a great picture of me somewhere
triathlete in that era without rocking
the stash at least at one point so all
pumped up coming up the sand ladder with
a mustache on it was it's a great shot
I've been looking for it I can't find it
so I do all these different races and uh
I get to I get to Penticton
and by by then I I got there's some
issues in the relationship because I've
been you know I've discovered this
passion for training
whatever
so I I go for a swim on Race morning
and that was the last time I ever saw my
wedding ring I get out of the water it
was bizarre when I read it in your book
and I was like Wow and I never found it
my ring is in my Okanagan I don't think
I ever told anybody that story mine's
somewhere off the coast of Jamaica and
and and we were separated at that stage
so it was kind of an Iron Man Widow
scenario yeah well it was you know it
was more than that I was a partner in
private Equity Firm there were some
years where I I would sleep in my bed
and in Hong Kong 150 times
so uh we're an international business
and I spent a lot of time on the road
and we just you know you we weren't
together and uh that was you know you
get sometimes you got to do things wrong
to learn how to do them right and I got
a great marriage now because I've I
basically do the opposite of what I did
the first time and and it's been it was
uh it was a difficult period but you
know I think we didn't have any kids and
we got out of it
well so why was I I'll tell you sorry
why was I wearing the ring I was wearing
the ring because you know I realized
that I was going to get divorced
but I was completely committed to
minimizing the damage
to everyone
in the whole situation including my my
ex-wife and and when people talk to me
about divorce I say you know
you're gonna have a good reason to go
after the other person and when people
are hurting and it's highly emotional
they might even give you that reason
because there's a sense they they want
it to be your fault and so they want you
to engage them in battle
and you you have to be smart enough and
in control enough to see past the moment
and see where you're trying to get to
and where I was trying to get to was out
of the marriage
and what's it going to take to get me
out of the marriage and I don't want to
fight and uh I don't want to argue about
anything and so I pretty much disagreed
to everything and got out of it and we
were young we both had great jobs there
wasn't there wasn't we could have fought
but there wasn't really anything to
fight about and so you know it was an
emotional time but we got we got through
it we both went on with our lives and
then I had that moment on the couch
where I ask myself is if this is it you
know if if the only thing left for me on
that path I was on was money I was the
only thing left for me I was very good
at my job I'd done it for a decade
and I used to sit in my office
with that Harbor View and I'd look out
and I just wanted to be out there I want
to be outside I didn't want to be in
this building and I was like you know
what
so ever my parents tell me I'm crazy my
grandma I visit her she's like oh you
can't you know are you sure and I'm like
I agree sorry to interrupt but like was
there a vision of what would be on the
other side of that or was it just a
sense of this is not right and I'm not
going to be able to figure out what is
right until I exit the only thing that I
knew that was right was leaving
I knew I had to leave
and I had no plan so I I ended up in New
Zealand but I went to Far North
Queensland first I went to Australia for
a month just because I had a bike
sponsor there and I don't know I just
tried it out and it was okay right so
hold on a second so prior to that though
I I would imagine of course you know
your colleagues and your peers are going
to tell you you're insane but then
there's also the argument of look if
you're not happy here and you want to
figure out something else like stay here
until you figure like keep one foot in
here until you figure out what the next
thing is why make the imprudent choice
of just leaving but from what I
understand though they gave you like a
one year leave of absence so first step
my boss is like just take take two
months
take two months and
see what you want to do so he's like
he's probably thinking to himself
Gordo just needs some time
he's gonna go away come to a sense he's
got divorced he needs a message exactly
we'll just let him go so in my two
months July August I start that with the
escape from Alcatraz and then I go to
Boulder and I'm in the foot I'm in the
mountains above us so I'm living up
Sugarloaf
so I'm living with a nurse not a
girlfriend situation it was a nurse that
had a spare room and I'm there for about
six weeks doing my triathlon training so
we've by the way we've rolled forward
now to my second season of triathlon and
it's it's I I'm Swim Bike Run every day
I pack my car up
drive down to Scott Carpenter pool do my
swimming do my training at the end of
the day I drive back up I really enjoy
that life
and so it gave me a chance to train like
a pro but I'm not I'm not a pro I I mean
by by this stage I'm kind of a fast age
grouper and I go up to Penticton and I
have a really good race and and I just
love it I love the whole thing about it
so after a decade of living in these
major metros doing Finance London
and Hong Kong I'm outside I'm running in
the forest it's beautiful
it's Colorado in the summer it's great
and so I I go back and then I negotiate
the leave of absence and so the last
time I worked
for the firm or in a desk situation it's
October 2000 say so I go back for a
couple months and they give me a leave
of absence for a year they're like you
know what you know if you you know maybe
come back but it was also a way when a
partner leaves a firm it can be a signal
that there might be a problem in The
Firm so but there's no problem I just
felt like doing something else and so it
let us manage my exit as well too so it
kind of worked out for everybody right
and hence begins this dive down the
rabbit hole yes that like you know it
just is mind-boggling like you you go so
deep into this I mean I don't even think
any like were there even any pros who
were as immersed in this training
lifestyle that you were and I'm
interested in your mindset and what led
to that because yes okay you're like an
amateur triathlete you're doing pretty
good that's a far leap from I'm gonna
just make this my entire life yeah well
that says a little something about the
ultra personality right yeah yeah yeah
so I mean
no I mean that's that's how I'm tired to
11 and Beyond
yeah we just I just I just go deep was
that
driven by a sense of possibility like I
think I could actually win one of these
races or was it just let me see what I'm
capable of like I want to challenge
myself and leave no unfinished business
on the table so when one is not yet not
not yet so now we're we're kind of 2
000 2001 I'm in New Zealand I've
connected with a guy called Scott Molina
Scott Molina is one of the original big
four triathletes over 100 race wins
amazing guy
huge capacity to exercise
and my vibe then is I was born to do
this I feel like I finally arrived at
something that is me so it's my um
it's just my thing that knowingness
intuition I'm I'm on the path and this
path is my path for right then the other
thing is I notice when I'm doing these
long rides sometimes I'm working through
all this baggage this emotional baggage
this Karma whatever you want to call it
I have you know this is back before we
all had airpods and and that so I'm just
I'm just out there on a chip seal Road
getting blasted by kiwi winds and stuff
but I'm working through all these
motions and all this tension and
everything that was in my body from all
those years sitting in a desk and so
it's very in some ways really
therapeutic sure and uh and it's just
great so I'm I'm developing emotionally
I'm becoming a better person but I don't
really have anybody to interact with uh
[Music]
Lena and the monk life right didn't you
buy a house down there for like close to
nothing like a five bedroom house for
like almost no money 110 000 U.S so
that's so crazy did you hold on to that
uh for a few years yeah it worked out
the the the
well the Kiwi dollar was blown out
and you know what at the at the time New
Zealand was panicking because they
thought the brain drained they thought
everybody was going to leave the country
and so you know I roll in and it's a
hundred and ten thousand to buy a five
bedroom house and you know that's kind
of like what my rent was in Hong Kong
for and and I was like I'm gonna do this
and and so so then I get the idea well
I can you know I can rent out a couple
rooms and now I have I can live for free
in Christchurch so I'm I'm viable so I I
can just do this for a couple years and
I only need I only need a few coaching
clients and the whole thing works
and and again not thinking forward but
my present you know my my plan works I I
got a sustainable uh life and uh and I'm
loving the training and then I would
alternate hemispheres and I just keep
getting faster
so the let's talk a bit about how
I end up at Ultraman yeah so first the
my first season
I signed up for Iron Man Canada and then
there's back then there's this thing
called the international it was the
first year they ever had the
international lottery for Kona
and nobody knew about it but I found out
and so I apply and I get a slot
so I'm the new guy at the triathlon swim
workout and I come in one day and I'm
like I got a slot for Kona and
everybody's like you and I was like yeah
I just applied to the lottery and I got
it so I do two Iron Mans in my first
season so I'm on the I'm at the pier
uh that October and there's just this
little flyer a piece of paper stuck to a
lamp post and it's about Ultraman
that's how you find out about it and a
janky flyer what year is this 2003 no
this is
1990.
October of 99 and it's on the lamp post
and I'm looking at the numbers
like swim six miles you know like ride I
mean what is it 274 or something uh for
miles it's 90 the first day and 171 yeah
second day I think and then the double
marathon and I'm like how could anybody
right do that like it's just so far out
of my reality
and um anyhow so I I keep doing so now
so I get decent you know my Iron Man
times are in the low nine hours I'm sort
of I'm you'd either call me a really
great age grouper or a slow Pro or
whatever and I'm like you know and I'm
and I'm and I'm loving the volume
and and so I'm like you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna go do Ultraman
and so this is
2002 and I didn't have any expectations
but I did a lot of training because I'm
I'm a pretty seasoned Iron Man athlete
then and uh and just paint the picture
on the volume because I'm not sure
people who are listening really
understand the extent of the volume that
you guys were putting in in New Zealand
yeah it's
it's it's difficult I mean sure we can
talk I mean it's got to be 30 35 hours
yeah it's 35 hours a week it's I mean
it's 10K I'm so I remember the first
time I ever swam 10 000 meters long
course in a in a session
and it took me so what would that be so
well I'm not I'm not as fast as you so
it probably I had to you know I grew up
with it so it probably took me pick that
up later three hours and 45 minutes
and I get out of the pool and I can't
move my arms and my my roommates had
left me because it's 10K back to my
house and I was like yeah I was like I'm
gonna jog home because I'm gonna I know
for Ultraman I'm gonna have to right do
it and so I'm like jogging home I can't
get my hands up for anything because I'm
jogging home hanging my arms
and I get home and I just go to bed and
I'm thinking to myself wow this is going
to be
it's gonna this is gonna be a tough
event
and that was the first time though and
then then I actually did a training camp
in Kona
where
um I I did a six mile swim in the ocean
three one uh from kahoe Bay so from the
Finish went three out three back that
blew up here oh three out and three back
to keho from kale so not from Kailua so
from the swim exit and uh that went
pretty well
and then I did another 10K and then I'm
noticing
okay I'm not really getting used to it
but I'm able to function afterwards and
so I start you know it turns out I got a
capacity for Ultra swimming
and we don't we don't I don't do a lot
of those 10K swims because it takes so
much out of me but it'd be stuff like
that uh seven hour rides uh on kiwi chip
sealed roads so you're getting like
vibrated like crazy and is this before
you start doing like the you did the
thing where you went all the way across
the United States that's later yeah
that's later and the Epic camps and all
of that uh you would go like like you
would you would go the the north to
south or South uh North across New
Zealand we did that we did the we did
the length of New Zealand there was one
camp where things got a little carried
away I think I might have done 85 hours
of training in 12 days I
including a marathon on the weekend that
was in the middle okay uh my body my
training buddy Kloss Berling he ran a
marathon too and he was like holding
four minute K's like in the middle of
that kind of week
and just because he could
uh and yeah we we did we did a lot of
volume
and um
we did we actually did more volume well
the Train the volume was appropriate
what we what we missed and what what we
would have been helped by was
understanding recovery better now
nowadays with heart rate variability and
the different methods people use to
monitor fatigue we ignored a lot of
fatigue right and ignoring fatigue is is
great because you can you can get
through it you know if you're doing well
you know in the book if you're doing
five Ironmans in a week and you get to a
rough patch in one Iron Man or any one
day event you're like this is just a
patch this is just a moment mentally
it's great you're going to go through it
you can get through stuff so we used to
take these regular athletes that were
good and we'd take them and we put them
through the ringer for like eight to
twelve days and then they would go back
to their races and they'd be at a whole
new mental level because it was just a
moment and they they don't have like the
next five days hanging over them or
anything it's like I just I just got to
get through this moment and this day is
going to be done before I know it so
that was that was one of the things I
had a moment similar to your moment I
think it was in
Maui where I got so tired
that all of a sudden it it just left me
and and tired you just have this feeling
of total acceptance and you're gonna
you're you're just gonna keep moving you
know and you go beyond the fatigue the
fatigue loses its emotional value or
content for you and you just you just
learn how to kind of keep rolling and
those those are useful skills but those
skills can also get you into trouble in
in a sense I mean both cloth and I had
issues with over training yeah class was
sick for three years yeah I remember
that that was kind of like an you know
pretty that was a big story like he just
couldn't he was he had such a massive
engine and capacity but he just flamed
out from doing too much and nobody
could figure out what was wrong he saw
so many doctors and then he connected
with one doctor in
I think it was the Bay Area and he had a
mold infection he had Epstein-Barr and
he had one other thing going on and this
doctor helped him get his health back
and then he came back at a very high
level he won Iron Man kalmar he went
really fast in Roth so he was able to
get back but when he when he came back
he never went that deep again in
training Having learned the lesson and I
think we I think the the athletes
from that era and from Molina's era
before us we we took a lot of risks with
our health that these days some risks
are necessary but you can take much more
intelligently as a Long Point those
moments more precisely when to choose to
go deep and when it's best to ease off
the gas a little bit well and something
you know the prop I took 10 years off to
raise my family and I come back and I'm
wondering is there is there a need for
my voice and a lot of the issues we're
talking about are the exact same issues
they just have different brand names now
in nutrition and stuff but something
that is new now is this concept of
dynamic loading so you're going to load
yourself when your body is ready to
adapt rather than Chuck a bunch of load
at the athletes and the fittest are
going to survive which is very much the
way it was done back in the day a
swimming particularly you have this
super wide pyramid we're going to throw
a ton of work at everybody and whoever
comes out the top we've weeded everybody
else out it's just a roulette wheel I
mean it was saying I I came up in that
era and it's just volume Beyond right
and then you just roll the dice on a
two-week taper and sometimes it works
out and sometimes it doesn't and that's
kind of it right and the training now
like we just I talked about this on the
podcast before but we just saw the world
championships in in Budapest and you see
17 year old kids
putting in performances that just to me
are unfathomable and when you're 17 like
how many years of real training have you
even had at that point right the
training is so different like they've
really figured out a new approach and
methodology that is you know miles
Beyond kind of what it used to be like
and the athletes out if you're an
athlete listening to this you need to
learn about Dynamic loading you need to
learn about heart rate variability you
need to learn about assessing your
Readiness your active readiness you can
you can tell if your body's ready to
load
and you can learn from your errors you
can actually see how you're adapting to
the load you can see when you're not
adapting to the load you know back in
the day I used to go out and do a seven
hour training day and then I go send a
email off to Molina and say hey my heart
rate was a little low today and I've
just put myself further in the hole
whereas today I would wake up I would
have my my Readiness test I would look
at my overnight right metrics and my
morning metrics and I'd be like hey this
is not a day to go do something like
that and so you get a much better
response to your training you still do
the work you still have to do a ton of
work but the idea is you do the work
when you're ready to adapt right and the
good news is you just published a blog
post on this called Dynamic loading via
daily Readiness assessments it's like a
classic Gordo blog post and if you think
it's just about checking your aura ring
or your whoop score in the morning oh no
so this goes way deeper than that it
goes way deeper I was like do I need a
HD to understand this blog post well
here's the other thing so the who do I
get who do I relate to in sport
I relate to practitioners
the people because I've done it so I
relate to other people who have done it
so John hellermann's in New Zealand
Scott Molina athletes coaches doctors
practitioners people who have done it I
speak the same language as them
so this act of Readiness in a blog you
talk about it came to me because there's
a there's a Swedish speed skater called
Nils who broke
the world record for the 5K and the 10ks
the world champion gold medal now Niels
has a coach called Johan and and Johan
has something in common with you and me
he's done a otilo yeah which is this
Epic
swim run event where you go down the
archipelago in the Baltic
and I and so after Niels breaks the
world record he writes his Manifesto and
and he's probably 25 years younger than
me
so not not quite old enough to be my
grandkid but definitely you know it's
kind of like a generation removed so
anyhow so before I read the manifesto
how to win a 10K
um and we should just say let me just
interject quickly sorry to interrupt but
this Manifesto that you're about to
describe if you're like in on endurance
Twitter like this just lit the internet
on fire like everybody was reading this
and dissecting it it was a it was a big
story we've talked about it on the
podcast before it was like some kind of
Bible has now been you know kind of
divinely delivered upon us with the
answer to how to achieve great endurance
I mean it's it's how to skate dot SC
if you're an endurance athlete you need
to read it and if you want to talk about
it just add me on Twitter because I love
I love it so anyway you know after they
break the world record this tweet just
appears from Johann saying to Alan and
me it's just like hey I just want you to
know
I read your guys stuff
20 years ago and it really helped me hmm
that's cool but get this
Niels
is from a small town in Sweden called
trollhotton
trollhoten is where a guy called Bjorn
Anderson grew up Bjorn's one of my
training Partners from way back along
with colting and beerling just a beast
on the bike total Beast so like he had
the most amazing legs I've ever seen in
my life it had VO2 like above 80 mid 80s
just an amazing
specimen superhuman specimen and so this
little town in Sweden kicks out these
two superhumans Nielsen Buren and Niels
writes the manifesto so I read the
manifesto and this is it this is so what
they did was they took everything from
my ultra days from my Iron Man days that
I learned from Molina they took it and
they made it better and how did they
make it better they made it better with
radical recovery this concept where they
take the two days off so five days of
loading so you take a whole week of
elite cycling and you pack it into five
days and then you for two days you just
chill
and you do it over and over and over and
you get more and more aerobically fit
like just amazing Fitness and then they
then they put together their the the
threshold preparation and then they do
the specific prep to break the record
it's an amazing story but the back also
has three years of daily training logs
in it and so you know you dig into it
and so for somebody like me it's just a
gold mine I'm just like looking and he's
totally honest like he's he he gets
wrecked and he has to take a week off
and then he goes and does some sort of
ultra race and then he has to take
another week off I mean like so he kind
of breaks all the rules in the early
days but then he connects with Johan and
they figure it out
and it's just it's just an amazing story
because you know then obviously you get
the medal you break the record it has a
happy ending and so so I see this
narcissist I was so inspired but there
was a little piece of me that felt sad
because I was there I was doing the work
I was I was doing the work and I was
like oh that was it the recovery so I'm
like well it's not too late
that you know I mean yeah I'm still
alive and so what I've done is and
there's a series of blogs about it as a
now as a 53 year old
the father of three I'm sort of I'm like
you know what let's see if these
principles still work on my body and so
that's what I'm working on now that's
that's my project and you're working
with Johann as your coach yeah that's
just the best part is is the ability to
to to to connect and really go full
circle
with Johan and help him with his
preparations so you know we're taking a
speed skater we're turning them in in a
sense I'm trying to help them with
swimming because one of the neat things
about when you're working kind of a lead
to a lead or coach to coach is you
already know how to train you know your
body really well and so it's I I like to
think of it more as a we're like
technical consultants to each other so
we sort of speak the same language and
we have this we have this basis of
respect for work and so he's he's
helping me with some of my blind spots
which is recovery so obviously if you're
training at Nielsen's level and you
don't get the recovery right you totally
nuke yourself yeah so but same deal with
me you know I'm I'm older I don't
recover as well and so we're trying to
put those principles together and then
we're also trying to learn and and
trying to make this whole adaptive
loading so we get better loading uh into
the bodies and we get a better result
and by documenting it all and doing the
math like you love to do hopefully there
are deeper and greater are insights that
can be canonized for everybody else yeah
and and here's another thing
it's a form of self-hypnosis
so one of the things about athletic
performance
is that the more you believe in your
plan the better it works
so yeah
I mean whatever plan I have at any stage
of my life I always believe it's the
best plan or I have to change it and so
it's it's very much I mean yeah I I mean
my friends laugh at me because they're
like yeah you always think you're right
what is the plan for like what is the
you know in what direction are you
headed right well that's the beauty of
it
the the my my account on trading Peaks
is always asking me like what's your
race you know what's your event and
eventually I got sick of it asking me so
I just said get fit and and the the date
was my 57th birthday and I'm just trying
to get fit and so and this gives me a
huge advantage
because I have nothing hanging over my
head I have no reason to rush
and so I can just do it right and enjoy
the process and see what happens
and share it with people
and I'm and really what am I I'm living
my next book I'm I'm living it and I'm
blogging it and I'm sharing it with
people and what I learn I'm just putting
it out in the world and so it's just a
whole experience and and one of the the
best
you don't need a you don't need a race
to be winning you know you can just you
can just go out and live it and it's
just been so engaging for me to be back
into it and then you get all the
positive neurochemistry from base
training if you if if you actually ask
endurance athletes especially Ultra
endurance athletes the part they like
the part they love it's the base
training it's the easy training outside
when there's no Pace pressure and you're
not trying to achieve anything or you
don't have to hit any splits and you can
just enjoy it yeah you feel that Fitness
in your legs when you hit a climb but
you're keeping it all you know dialed to
a certain exertion level so that it's
fun and you're not walking around like a
zombie all the time that's the part that
I really don't want in my life anymore
so the five two
it's great and my and my am I Readiness
metrics if I I'm not because I've set up
a system where I can't put myself in the
hole it just becomes obvious you know my
HRV for training app turns yellow and I
don't want it to turn red on me so I
gotta back off and and just so people if
they're not familiar with the app it
checks some stuff going on with your
heart your heart rate variability your
morning resting heart rate and before
before it tells you to stop it kind of
gives you a yellow light this this
yellow thing and and then I've got my
other metrics and I I just have to back
off and then even if I have a great five
days and normally you know back in the
day I try and just keep it going I got
to shut it down so you never get too
tired and and I think it it strikes me
as a as a neat experiment
the other thing is I talk about it with
serious athletes and they say oh you
know it sounds good but I don't think
that's for me and and I would I was that
athlete when I was Elite and there's a
guy called Hunter Kemper he used to take
Sundays off and we thought he was nuts
because he was giving us a day you know
like one one extra day of training and
and so he he was Radical then and then
Niels comes does the hardest training
I've ever seen in my life and he's taken
two days off a week and you're thinking
well if it works for him how about just
a more regular guy you know some some
guy in his 50s it's probably probably
going to work okay for me so that that's
where I got the idea from yeah there's
certainly no cost if you can break a
world record
10K skate
on two days off a week I mean I don't
know how anybody else could justify that
it's going to hold them back right right
but isn't there an argument that what he
is doing in those five days becomes so
superhuman I mean he's putting in like
just massive amounts of work into those
five days well so the argument would be
wouldn't it be better if you spread that
out over six days I would say come and
watch because what I'm doing is I'm
compressing my modest week into five
days so I'm giving myself my five day
dose is pretty good last five days was
20 hours of training in five days for
you know that's a lot that's a lot
and it's compressed and so you you get
this overload but the idea is it's
overload you can manage
and I think that's part of the reason
why it works I I don't necessarily think
the radical Parts actually in the
training I think the radical Parts in
the recovery I think there's there's
something about because you end up if
you actually look at how many hours you
get off in the in the two day it ends up
being like 60 hours and that's actually
and and Niels talks about it in the
manifesto he talks about this hormonal
reset and so you come into each cycle
really craving training in a sense so
there's there there's probably something
physiological going on
here's another thing I want to put out
there for people too another change I've
made I'm I'm heavy
and I know you said I look fit when when
we look very fit I I am you don't look
heavy at all okay well I'm about I'm
about
170 pounds okay now if I was an elite
runner on my frame I'd probably want to
go down to 158
and as an elite Ironman athlete I used
to like to get down to about 163. okay
I think there's and one of the things
Niels he was when he was in his base
training he was he was about 11 pounds
heavier than race weight okay and that
was about the biggest swing that I would
have
and when I was at my absolute strongest
in doing my biggest training I was
relatively heavy and I felt like it was
a disadvantage back then so that's a
change I've made I've made a conscious
decision to be a little heavy and not to
be in this situation where I'm always
trying to cut weight or in a in a bit of
a slight energy deficit and stuff and I
think this also helps recovery so when
you're doing these five-day overloads or
whatever overload people are using if
you're a little heavy a little heavier
and you talk about your avocado
sandwiches a lot in the book yeah well I
I've you know I think there's a lot of
disordered eating especially in
Triathlon and there is this obsession
with power to weight and being as lean
as possible and I think there is
something to be said for for being lean
to a certain extent on race day but
during the heavy training you know what
is the downstream impact on your
hormones for example you know how are
you able to absorb the training when you
are like paper thin at that point and I
I've made that mistake when I went to
Ultraman in 2011 I was like 158 it was
the skinniest I'd ever been and I ended
up getting a respiratory infection and
dnfing like I couldn't you know I
couldn't handle it
so Kloss and I when we both went over
the edge we had been very lean for a
very long time
and the toughest part about it is it
feels
great so the stress hormones associated
with being underweight
combined with the high intensity
training
it feels good so you feel great right up
until the moment where you're done and
so carrying a little bit of extra weight
I think you get a better adaptation from
the training but I also think it
de-risks the lifestyle quite a bit like
and and uh
but it goes against the mindset and it
goes against a lot of the positive
feedback that the ultra Community gives
each other
um but I don't have anybody to impress I
don't have a race coming up happily
married to my wonderful wife and we're
good you know and so if I'm you know if
I'm built more like a fireman than an
elite triathlete now it's cool she's
okay with it so I don't have any real
pressure with that so so I want to put
that out there and because you know the
fastest man in the world right now he
might not necessarily be the skinniest
athlete Molina used to say the same
thing too he used to say look if it was
all about weight they'd have scales
instead of Finish Lines but it's a
mindset thing for us in this community
and it's it's um there's just something
about that being Greyhound lean that
just feels great and but I don't think
it works and in the sense if you look at
Christian Blumenfeld he doesn't look
like that
he's great he looks very powerful and
and also they they know performance I
mean we should all be paying a lot of
attention and you think back to some of
the great athletes over time uh great
cyclists people that were able to do
some amazing training their physiology
was like a stockier physiology and if
you're a recreational athlete or even a
very serious amateur athlete uh I would
say you know you're probably going to
get a better result rolling it a little
heavier and it's certain and the reality
is it's a little heavier but the way
it's going to feel to you is a lot
heavier like I feel gigantic right now
but you know just because it's just the
mindset thing you have that endurance
athlete mindset all right well let's get
back to we're still talking about
Ultraman your Ultraman race oh
it was so a life-changing experience it
really was
it was it was it it was um
my brother was there and he was kind of
my crew chief and this was 2002 2002 is
when it went well
and and so we line up and uh
I'm heading out on the swim and I come
out first
so the TR like the training works so I
come out I'm leading the race
and I treat it like a one-day race I
just hit the bike as hard as I can and
because I know I'm gonna be okay I've
done a lot of volume and I'm like at
least I'll win day one and I do and uh
and it goes great and our course is
different that year that was when you
start and finish every day in Kona so we
don't go around oh yeah that's right I
forgot about that yeah so you didn't go
up you didn't have the volcano climb I
would have loved that but didn't have it
because they were trying a new thing
might have been something to do with
permits or maybe there was an issue with
the Red Road being closed back then
because of uh a bit of lava flows or
something
so we uh so it goes great
and then day two uh it's basically you
ride out to Javi on the Ironman course
to go over the kohalas then you drop
down the far side of Waimea saddle turn
around come back take the upper Highway
and then drop into Kailua
uh so I just
I I think we all it's not draft legal so
we gotta spaced it out we spaced it out
it get a few gaps and I just I just wait
until the climb and then I just full gas
up the kohala's just right away from
everybody and that was kind of it I had
a bit of a a low spot around 100 miles
and uh but I was far enough ahead that
nobody noticed but I was actually riding
with my feet out of my shoes for a while
um because my feet hurt so much but then
I got through it and uh won that day
and then so Molina reaches out to me
and he's like okay so you can win this
thing now
and what you got to do is the only way
they're gonna beat you
is if they convince you
to start fast yeah on the marathon
so you got to promise me that you're
gonna
not do that because you know like
because he knows this is big for me like
this this is and and so I I follow I'm
good at following his advice and I go
out and sure enough they kind of take
off
and uh who is the big Runner that year
oh
I think
Don Fink I think was one of the guys
that was off Tony was off the front too
I think
and there is but it wasn't it wasn't
like trying to it wasn't like trying to
run with Peter kotlin or something right
like Colin wasn't right yeah I mean that
guy he got like 520 or something like
that
so it was but they they take off and so
I I just let him go I do my thing
because I got a cushion from the two
days and and I and I just and I run and
it gets really hard and there's a
picture of me we went into the did you
go into the energy lab on the way back
no okay so we go we just started Javi
and go straight so if you're starting in
Kona are you running up to Javi
we go halfway out to the lava field out
and back
but on the way back you go into the
energy you gotta go in the energy lab
with about
40 miles in your legs or something and
it's so hot coming out so there's a
picture of me at the final turnaround
which is the Iron Man turn around in the
energy lab
and uh I got these baby blue try shorts
on but but I'm bleeding right and I
don't know it because the saddle swords
and all the Chafe and everything so I
got these two like lines of blood kind
of like on on the front I'm so gone and
you got no idea like how wrecked you are
and they were giving me mile splits
and then they go to half mile splits
and then what I didn't know was I was
going so slow that my brother told them
just to lie to me about my splits
because I was so out of it and he but he
knew I was going fast enough to win the
thing so he's like we're we're just
going to give him the same split and so
it was good he got me through and then
you know there's that magic Point you're
5K from home and you realize you can
walk it in and still win the race and
then you start feeling a bit better and
kind of stagger in so I didn't at the
time I was happy to win but I didn't
realize what that race would do to me at
the time Molina just said hey
enjoy the sunset enjoy the moment you're
not going to have many moments like this
in your life
and and what happened though is after
this childhood and this this life and
finance I it was like a rebirth I saw
myself as an athlete from there on in
and that was when I realized I could win
an Iron Man um
when I when I won that race and it
completely changed my identity as a
person and ever since that day I've
thought of myself as an athlete and so
it was a it was a it was a
transformative experience
there is something really unique and
special about that race and I remember
you saw it first time on a flyer I read
an article in like competitor magazine
or something like that and I think it
was the year that that Goggins had done
it but
I vividly recall the way in which the
race was described
which was that it was this like
spiritual Odyssey right like yes it's a
race it's a world championship and I
think it was maybe Jane you know Bacchus
who was quoted and saying like but the
most important thing is that everybody
who endures this experience athletes and
their crew members are transformed in
the process of traversing the island and
and that really spoke to me it was like
that when I read that I was like that's
what I'm looking for I'm trying to I'm
trying to transform my life like this is
a vehicle or a catalyst for that and I
think there is something really powerful
about that island and the configuration
of that race that is conducive to that
and I know lots of people whose lives
have been transformed in different ways
but for it to you know provoke this
Epiphany in you I mean obviously winning
is no small thing
but I think it's more than just winning
that race it's like that place and that
specific race that location that course
the the kind of community aspect of of
you know what is entailed and in doing
that thing is is really unique
there's a picture on the internet
of David coming out of the water
and it's the same swim Finish Line
and I look at that picture and I feel
connected to him and it's the most wild
powerful feeling to be connected to
somebody like that through the race and
I think everybody that's done that race
we all share a connection and it's just
it was a just a wonderful experience
so let's talk about the power of the
island yeah
so that year when I win it I come out of
the I'm leading the swim I come out and
I'm trying to empty my goggle and what I
don't know is I've been stung by a
jellyfish my eyes swollen shut and I'm
terrified because I think they're gonna
pull me from the race
and I I get to my bike and I just I'm
like I gotta get out of here okay before
the docs pull me from the race or
something because I got hit by the
jellyfish and it wasn't too bad that
year I ride and after about
45 minutes or so moving the body clears
the toxins and I'm good to go but the
next year off magic Sands I swim through
the jellyfish and I go into anaphylactic
shock and I nearly die and my my I get
picked up by a boat and they they drive
me to the pier and they lay me on the
pier the ambulance is coming but they
got to get back out to the race in case
something goes down with somebody else
and so I'm just lying there sweating
like crazy when the ambulance rolls up
and they take take me to the
hospital and I'm getting a lot of
attention and that there's 10 people
around me and I can't see myself
but I'm like going full full shock and
uh and for days afterwards every time I
would come off the meds I'd I'd start
swelling up again and stuff so we don't
know kind of what happened but that was
the end
of my Open Water right my ocean swimming
career and that was the end that was
that was the end of Ultraman for me uh
not a Pele and the island had decided
you've had enough yeah you got your
Victory time for you to move on to
something else exactly and I do you know
I know this story but I I didn't know it
was that serious or that bad like I
thought yeah how bad could it have been
you got sunk busted he went to the
hospital now he won't go in the ocean
anymore like so am I so I I swear so I
swim through
and immediately I feel it's like a huge
chemical burn and my paddler
says to me well you'd be all right you
know like because the year before we
swam through it and I'm like no you need
to get you need to get me to a hospital
now and so it's like right angle and
he's powering into magic Sands and then
the boat picks up and then we're in the
boat and they're like hey how you doing
you good and I was like you need to call
an ambulance I need to get to a hospital
now like I have this feeling inside me
that things are going wrong very quickly
and so I knew I knew that it was it was
over at that stage and so I talked to
the doctor the ER Doc and I sort of like
all right well you know if you had to
if you had to give it marks how would
you score my reaction she said well one
is not a problem 10's dead you were nine
you can't go back in the uh you can't go
back in the ocean again
and and that was it now there happens to
be one place in the world where I can
actually swim and that's Bora Bora
because it's a lagoon and the way the
wind blows I'm good
so I did some training there for a tilo
uh long Open Water swimming with my wife
so I have done a little bit of ocean
swimming but you know it's like EpiPen
around and you got to be really careful
so what happens when uh when you're
swimming in the Stockholm archipelago oh
you know that story and no I don't know
that I know I don't know the story all I
know is my experience doing it there's
jellyfish everywhere now these jellyfish
don't sting but they are ubiquitous I
mean everywhere throughout the that
entire day just thousands and thousands
of jellyfish still running around you
it's
a cultic and I are doing the race and by
this time I'm uh we're we're doing the
Race we're leading the race
he's in the he's he's a phenomenal
athlete right it's everything I I got to
stay on his feet I mean I I might have
led I don't know 200 meters of the 15K
of swimming we did that goddamn guy is
so damn handsome and good at sports it's
ridiculous uh my friend Justin Dara says
it's how a man should be I mean he's if
you were gonna if well I mean he's the
Nordic God isn't he yeah I mean he
really is it's like something out of
Mythology he's tall he's strong he's
athletic so it's this little Bay you
it's this little track and uh you know
he goes in and he's off I go in there's
jellyfish everywhere yeah and there's
just nowhere and so there's just nowhere
to go so I was just like all right well
this is it this is it and I just start
swimming through all the jellyfish and
I'm not getting stung I'm good so it was
it worked out but it was it was
definitely psychologically you know
freaking you out well I had had it in
New Zealand too I I had it did a half
Ironman race and I figured I'd be good
because it was cold water it wasn't like
the blue bottles that had got me the
Hawaiian box jellyfish
but it was I was I had a real tough time
on that swim just
trying to stay calm because the
jellyfish are all going through here
having a little bit of a flashback but I
got past the whole thing I think the
most impressive race that you've done is
is winning otello like the fact that you
weren't you didn't grow up as a swimmer
and you were able to like
compete at that level in that race I was
so humbled in my experience doing that
like the minute the gun went off and we
started like we jumped into the water
and got to the end of the first you know
swim
I realized like oh I haven't prepared
for this race properly at all like I
have no idea what I'm doing
and just got my ass kicked and held
Health back like the entire day I just
felt terrible about the whole thing well
we were of we were we were lucky we were
very well balanced team so I was just
fit enough to stay on his feet
and he was really driven at the
beginning of the race and then in the
early days some of the people weren't
all that happy the race was going on and
we were so far out in front we we got
lost on the long run
and so we ended up I think it's supposed
to be I don't know I think it's supposed
to be like a 20K run or something down
the big island
um oh yeah there's that half marathon
like two-thirds of the way in yeah and
we ended up banging out 30k because we
got lost and another team got in front
of us and so we get lost because
somebody pulled the flagging off colting
Flags down a postman with one of those
European bikes uh that you see like in
Old paintings and they they start he's
telling this guy his tale of Woe like we
got lost it's not my fault it's all
happening in Swedish it's like how do we
get back and so the postman knows away
so he gets us back and then we find out
we're down to the Swedish Special Forces
team or whatever it is and so we were
just like we gotta get moving and as
triathletes you know a long run is
probably the only you know is a good
spot to kind of catch up so we just
Crush ourselves and we can we can see
them when we get to when we get to the
water and we just we we just reel them
in reel them in reel them in the last
run the short run we come out of the
water together
with this team and colting locks up as
soon as he stands up and I'm just like I
mean you lock up after like seven hours
I mean that could be it that last run up
to the Finish Line uphill not that one
so there's a little roller though that
you go over before you go down and then
run up to the finish line so he he's
locking up so I get in behind him and I
I push him as hard as I can to the to
the top of the hill he gets to the top
of the hill he's not cramping anymore
and he's gone I was like hey bud you
gotta wait I can't keep up
and so we we end up winning I mean once
once we Gap the guys they sort of shut
it down a little bit so we end up
winning by three minutes or something
but like I didn't know this but colting
had like booked like good morning Sweden
or something for the next morning
because he he was he was pretty
confident that like we were gonna have a
good day and so it was all unraveling
for him like in the middle and then it
comes back and so we have this it was
just such a great experience because we
we feel like the day's lost we're lost
and then we have to chase up and then we
managed to win it at the end and it was
it was a really phenomenal day and the
geography and the nature of that race
just in and out of the water and just
being outside all day it that was the
best day
or one of the best days of my entire
life I mean it's definitely top ten it
was just so great and the preparation so
in terms of being ready for the swim I
was prepared so I had done a a ton of
swim run I had done a lot of very
challenging five mile swim sets Open
Water we'd be doing Open Water towel
drags Open Water medley all kinds of
stuff to get our get ourselves ready for
the ocean and just have that strength
endurance
and then it helps to have quilting along
because you really do feel like you got
a shot so your motivation's pretty high
and he knows the course and he's been
doing it forever and he's sort of the
prince at that race but we should
probably point out for people that are
listening who have no idea what we're
talking about
otilo is the World Championships of
something called swim run it's a race
that's held annually in the archipelago
of islands off the coast of Stockholm
it's a 70 kilometer race I believe where
you Traverse how many islands like 35
Islands or something like I think
there's something like 52 transitions
you do the whole thing in a modified
wetsuit with your running shoes on the
rules are such that you can bring
whatever Aid you would like as long as
you carry it the entire way so people
have hand paddles and pull buoys
strapped to their legs and it's very
strange you know to see these these
athletes running around in wetsuits
crossing the island you jump in the
water the water's freezing on our day we
had like sideways rain and crazy off and
the conditions were terrible which kind
of made it more epic although not
enjoyable in the moment and I was yeah
like I mean Jonas was there that year
just doing it for fun and you know I
just I trained by I mean I did a lot of
swimming but it was mostly in the pool
and then trail running you know in Los
Angeles what I did not train for and was
completely ill prepared for was all the
technical climbing around and traipsing
through the mud and like hauling
yourself up on these rocks and sliding
down on your ass into the what like just
trying and I had the wrong shoes they
didn't have grip and so these like slabs
of rock that you have to like kind of
come out of the water up on like I'm and
then I'm watching these Swedish Special
Forces guys who look like ballerinas on
these rocks and I was like I I'm I'm
just I'm in the wrong place for this
right now
it's a it's a neat concept I mean just
dreaming it up I mean it amazing what an
experience and what a what a
beautifully curated experience that the
you know the founders and the organizers
have have really manifested like it it's
it's special yeah so
why do I want to get fit again
I'd like that to be the last thing I'd
like to be that how I mean it's not the
last thing but I but I think
that I can build up
if I'm fortunate and patient I can build
up about the time my son is able to make
it
because we're going to cross at some
point I think about the time we're
crossing in terms of physical capacities
we might be able to go do something like
that together and so colting has a
a race weekend and he does a short swim
run in Sweden in June so I'm going to
take my son there next year and we're
going to do a little one to see what he
thinks that's cool yeah that's really
cool I mean the other thing we should
point out is that yes you do it in
tandem you do it with a teammate and you
have to stay within like three meters of
your teammate the entire time and I
think that's I'm mean for me that's part
of what makes that event special is that
team aspect and that's all probably why
I had such a great day is because we
each contributed to our day and we had a
great outcome and that that's that's
part of the attraction from doing it
with my son too it could be something
and it'll also I think swimming is a
great thing for Life yeah and it would
give him a reason to keep swimming uh is
to have this goal out there uh in his
teens a lot of boys drop out of swimming
uh you know when they get to that high
school age and and I think if we could
kind of keep them in the game he'll be
glad that he kept it going later in life
yeah cool
um well speaking of life you know one of
the things that that makes you so
compelling to me I mean we've gone down
this deep Rabbit Hole of like total
endurance geekdom but what's really
resonant in in who you are and kind of
what you do is that you were able to
kind of graduate from that on some level
and so much of the advice and the kind
of principled way that you that you live
your life is oriented around like what
you learned from endurance and how
that's applicable to you know basically
living a good life that's grounded in
your values and and really prioritizes
like how you allocate
uh your resources from time to finances
uh you know parenting
Etc so that's kind of like the direction
that I want to take this right now I'm
so glad you brought that up so um
I'm uh 42 years old
and one of the fastest 40-something
triathletes in the world
at an amateur level now
and take a look around
I got a two-year-old
and a baby son at home and I
I just look at how we're all living all
of us and my peers the elites the elites
with kids
and I asked myself a question not the
question but a question I was like is if
I keep doing this where is this going to
take me where is this going to take my
family
and I'm not comfortable with the answer
I'm not comfortable with what I tell
myself and I'm like I got to make a
change
and that's and and it wasn't to do with
how anybody else was living it was it
was it was very much internally driven
it was where I wanted to be the man I
wanted to be the father I wanted to be
where I wanted to take my family and I
was like I'm Gonna Leave It
and I did I left it and I I was like I'm
gonna put my
and put my marriage first I'm gonna put
being a father first and I'm gonna I'm
gonna do that and it was awful it was so
hard at the beginning because you have
no skills
and
if you're a parent and you're listening
and it's awful
I know it I know it's awful for you and
it is
and what would I tell you I would tell
you well I tell you two things
definitely first I say it's temporary
it's not going to last and I would
encourage you to reach out to the best
teachers that you come across people
that have been with kids for their whole
lives particularly Preschool teachers if
you're going to get triggers you'll get
triggered by a toddler preschool
teachers are angels
and if you come to them with an open
heart and you're willing to learn and
use the techniques that they teach you
your life will get better it's not going
to be great
you're but you're going to be able to
cut those difficult moments in half and
that can be the difference between
falling apart and and not staying
involved and and being a successful
parent
and I would also say particularly to the
moms you you need to be realistic with
your expectations of yourself you need
to be taking care of yourself and and
really what's your what's your goal well
the goal my goal as a father is to
persist
and not retaliate
those are the two things those are those
are those are number one and number two
and if I'm having a good day and I'm
skillful maybe I can de-escalate almost
every situation so it's persist don't
retaliate and the skill is in the
de-escalation so maybe share an example
of that in practice
in practice it's it's well there's
there's a lot of distraction involved
with kids I mean one of the best
Preschool teachers used to carry a
Leatherman around in his pocket and when
the four-year-olds were starting to get
a little wound up he would pull out his
Leatherman and he would just go up have
you ever seen my Leatherman and he would
just pull a a tool out and it's kind of
shiny and he would pull a tool out of a
screwdriver or something and the kids
just be mesmerized and so it's the art
of distraction and just because because
the kids don't want the other thing is
you know as adults we put all this stuff
on the kid
oh they're they're being that way or or
they're like we create this whole story
around this difficult kid but there is
no story The the kid is just a a kid and
if you can get through the moment or
maybe distract them or give them a hug
or something I mean it it's gone
and kids have no memory
and oh
and so when you're you need to remember
that the the child that gave you such a
difficult time doesn't exist anymore
that's another really powerful one
because you can you can you can have
this Trauma from going through the
experience of living with preschoolers
and toddlers you can you can be really
traumatized from all the noise I mean
anybody that's an ultra endurance
athlete needs a lot of quiet time noise
really affects me
um and you can hold these resentments
against a situation and a child that
doesn't even exist anymore it's
completely gone the the it's a it's a
different child and to get around this
and to teach myself that I don't talk
about how my kids were I talk about
little axel or little Lexi was that way
there's a differentiation and I teach my
kids that I I teach them that they have
this illusion that they are the same
person that they were a couple years ago
but they're not and they're and they're
free to be a different person and that
person that they used to be doesn't
actually exist anymore and you can even
go deeper you say well actually that
person never existed
um but but you most kids will be able to
get that this concept that well you know
I kind of seem different but I but but
I'm not kind of the same continual
person but as parents and adults and in
family systems
it's a it's a big transition for the
parents when you go from kid to adult
and then you go from adult to Elder
these are all major shifts and the
relationship needs to shift too so you
need to kind of let go of all that prior
bag as you're process it somehow
um and so that so for parents that's
that's the persist don't retaliate
um and forgive forgive yourself forgive
the kids forgive the past
I like that idea of you know hitting up
the preschool teachers too it's like
that's a to me that's an example of you
as a learner always seeking for the
teacher or the mentor whether it's Scott
Molina or whoever it is like how can I
find that that person
um who can teach to be teachable at all
times and to be the person who has the
humility to say I don't have the answer
but I can find these other people that
do and I'm gonna listen to them here in
Boulder
there is a preschool that sits under
naropa
so it's a Buddhist preschool but I mean
a Buddhist preschool is I mean it it'd
be different well it's not like you're
getting a religion class or something
like that but the vibe and um it's
called Alia
and if you're going to spend money on
education for your kids it's going to
make a difference do it when they're
preschoolers that would be my advice
and if you happen to have a boy that's
challenged with socializing
skills and early intervention with very
patient Preschool teachers can really
really help that kid and it'll be in
ways that you don't see because the kid
will learn skills so our kids are you
know they're they're anywhere from nine
to a teenager now and they're still
using the skills the get along skills
that they picked up from three years at
this Buddhist preschool and it's it it's
transformative and I saw how well it
worked and I knew that we were clueless
a lot of parents think I mean yeah you
have a right to an opinion but you don't
necessarily have any skills and and the
teachers the people in the school system
they have a lot of skills and they've
seen a lot of different kids and they
can they can really help you out at a
very difficult time many parents of
young children
don't realize the magnitude of the
stress they're under from the disrupted
sleep from the whole situation and they
they have this feeling that that things
are unraveling on them but it's just
stress and so one of the things we used
to do
was we would we would uh do date nights
but we would uh we would alternate so we
would try and get each of us once a week
would have 24 hours or at least a a one
night where we didn't get yelled at by
by the Toddlers and and I called it like
a nervous system reset and it really
helped me because it I I knew that I
would get this break somewhere in the
week from the the day in day out of the
bedtimes and and that right and I think
the trick is
to you know overcome that sense that
that there's that that that's like
self-indulgent or you're being selfish
like you can't show up and be the the
parent that you want to be when you're
completely depleted it's back to like
the recovery question you know like how
it's it's it's less about
the quantity of time spent and more
about like elevating the quality of the
time spent and when you're not in your
best state maybe you know take a back
seat to you know too much interaction
until you can kind of recalibrate so
let's talk a bit about that that's how I
live my life
so when we were in it so we had three
under four
when our third was born and so
effectively two babies and a toddler and
you know a lot of people opt into very
challenging situations taking the whole
family on vacation driving places and
cars we we did the opposite I was like
you know what we're going to spend money
on child care so we can spend time with
each other and the approach was Child
Care is meant to benefit the marriage
and and it's not meant to give Mom a
break or whoever the lead parent is a
break it's meant to benefit the marriage
so if we're spending money on child care
we're doing it so that we're making our
marriage stronger because that's the
best thing we can do for this family is
keep ourselves together keep ourselves
engaged and just get through this
because it it is going to end you'll
you'll come out of it and I think that's
a a key thing so if you think you're
spending saving money for college you're
going to send the kids off to private
school I would say reevaluate that fancy
vacations and stuff
child care benefits the marriage and now
the other thing is
I have the capacity to go to be in a
very high paying profession
if I if I do that the beneficiaries of
that will be my adult children
then I never spent time with and I made
a choice to spend time with them young
and give them a human capital benefit of
my presence and my capacity to parent
and lead and Coach them rather than
accrue assets and financial wealth that
I would pass on to them
which they don't really need they should
be earning that themselves that's their
obligation the way they want to live
their lives and so I took a human
capital approach
to the family system and I I gave them
time when they were young and the the
benefit of that is I learn how to
interact in a different way with kids
and I and I bring those skills out to
the The Wider world like if you can't
get if you're not going to get rattled
by a four-year-old or a couple of couple
of toddlers you can go out into very
difficult situations in the world and
still think rationally and so it's a
useful skill but the other thing is it
gives me a chance to pass My Philosophy
off to them and and you know when we're
hiking in the Hills or stuff like that
we have this uh relationship and so we
develop a a powerful relationship so
that later in life
it can be a source of strength for the
family because I view the family as like
a a river in a sense you know each of us
is kind of coming in and out and we're
not going to be there the whole time I
think sometimes in the west we can think
of it very discreetly as you know it's
like my family as opposed to an Eastern
philosophy which is a family over time
and people are coming and going we're
having these life cycle events with
births and deaths and stuff and and if
you can be in that and pass that
philosophy on to your kids and that's
also why I dialed my coaching down
people ask me well who do you coach I
was like well I coach my kids you know
because that's where the big game comes
because if I don't coach my kids that
could also be a source of big regret for
me is not having taken that opportunity
and it's turned out it's turned out to
to be very rewarding for me
but you're talking about the limit that
how much you put in and and you don't
want to you want to limit it so that
your kids are seeing the best aspects of
yourself so that's why I like doing
stuff with them outside in my best
environment there's so much in there to
unpack but maybe the first thing that I
want to hear a little bit more about is
this this this this sort of idea that
you're coaching your kids like what is
the distinction or dividing line between
being your kids coach and being their
dad well yeah so let's talk about
well first off as a coach well this is
this is one of the things one of the one
of my difficulties with professional
sport
from an ethical point of view and my
personal values so I was an elite I was
not a professional an elite is somebody
that competes at a very high level a
professional makes a living and it's
about winning
the rules for a professional are
different than the rules for an elite I
I followed a different code in my racing
and I'm comfortable with the way I did
it but professional sport is very
different than it appears to somebody
that's not on the inside
so
similarly step back with my kids
relationship is always first
always first it's not about uh
performance it's not about trying to get
them somewhere what I'm trying to do is
deliver a skill set to them so that they
can live their life as they see fit
there's no there's no goal for me really
all I want to do is support them give
them a bunch of skills so they can just
go out in the world and do what they
want to do and and they'll do what they
do and they'll have the consequences of
whatever those choices are and they'll
they'll reap the benefits
so a lot of that is about well thinking
first off I don't want to mess it up so
if we happen to have
an Olympian a future president
an amazing musician in the house I don't
want my choice to constrain where they
can take their life so I want to I want
to keep as many options open for them as
they can so that that's kind of more my
coaching philosophy so we're not working
towards a goal
but I happen to have a skill set and if
they come to me and ask me for ideas I
can help them so our oldest wanted some
ideas this summer about well first you
wanted to have a personal trainer and I
said no you're not getting a personal
trainer I'm not I'm not doing that
because in this town kids have trainers
personal coaches and all that do they
really oh yeah oh wow it's so the keep
been up with the Joneses in Boulder as a
whole is literally keeping physically
keeping up with the Joneses
it's a whole I don't know man you know
like it's it's got to be heavy it's not
you know it's not just Olympians it's
like it's like what metal did you get I
mean it's it's like that and this is
like an Olympic Village like I was
sitting out at dinner the other day oh
Anton krupika rode his bike by and then
like a running group went by and who the
person I was eating with was like oh
she's national champion and this and
that I was like
you know and that's the environment
they're growing up in so it and they can
deal with it you know so I I also wanna
you know we we have I mean they're great
athletes but I'm a little bit torn
because I want them to be great people I
don't want them to be great athletes if
you're you know to be laying all the
cards on the table and and I think that
athletic path if it becomes about
winning it can really Lead You astray
um one of the things I tell my son is
hyper competitive is like be the best
Axel be the best you can be because he
gets wrapped up in winning and and
trophies and and and stuff and and I was
like you know what I mean that's great
but you can win and like and and really
have done not your best effort so you
should be the best you can be so I it's
it's value stuff so I want to kind of
pass pass that on and then in the
coaching side yeah if they come to me
and they want me to help you know we
hang out together and you know I like
lifting weights and so I teach them how
to you know lift weights and we do
indoor clown me together but it's really
about sharing that experience
sharing
an active life in nature like it's it's
hiking it's going out in the mountains
it's like climbing 13ers and 14 right
it's lots of skiing too you gotta ski a
lot well yeah and and let's talk about
skiing it's well first off it's it's
ridiculously expensive so you got to
really have your house in order
financially before you go down that path
some aspects of skiing it puts you in
that demographic uh uh certainly the
Aspen demographic is something that I
made a choice to leave when I left
private Equity I find it really
challenging it brings me right back to
my High Finance days I get very
competitive I get very focused on the
whole competing with money and stuff
when I'm in that environment it's
challenging for me but we do it let me
tell you how we do it we do it as a
non-competitive we don't race
we do it together we have fun together
there's no real way to keep score I mean
it's about style you know so my kids
would be like oh I skied that and I was
like well how do you know how'd it feel
do you feel like you did that with style
and we're just it's a it's kind of lower
key
and so that's um it's nice to have
something we can all do together
the um the real kind of like focus of so
much of your your writing and the stuff
that you share is really oriented around
you know crafting the life that you want
to live and how to do that you know by
getting clear on what your values are
and I wouldn't say that it's a
minimalist approach but it is an
approach of asking the reader or the
recipient of your content to really ask
themselves like you know what is it that
you actually need and if you're being
really honest with yourself like is that
thing that you're chasing the solution
to the problem that you're ignoring
right like you could be at a hedge fund
or you could easily step back into that
world and Make It Rain cash and you've
made a very conscious deliberate choice
to construct your life very differently
because you have Clarity on what's
important to you and so those choices
whether they be Financial or how you
allocate you know our most precious
resource and non-renewable resource
which is our time and attention to be
directed towards those Pursuits that
that bring your life the most meaning so
talk a little bit about you know how
you've you know crafted that philosophy
and and perhaps share a little bit about
you know how people can
consider these things in their own lives
okay what one thing
if it happened
would change everything
question I asked myself from time to
time
what one thing
so when I made the decision to step back
from
racing the one thing that would make a
difference in my life was a better
relationship with a three-year-old girl
that I was living with that one thing
and I was like that would really it
would help my wife
it would help it would help my my
daughter and it would really help my
family and so that's why I stepped back
and I was and I was very focused on that
one thing the relationship with the
little girl and we would do I had a
trailer in my mountain bike I put her in
the trailer and we'd go ride up hills
and stuff like I did Independence Pass
and she had a pillow and a and an iPad a
lunch box and and we do a lot of trips
just her and me and I built and it
wasn't it wasn't much fun but I built a
relationship and she's a wonderful young
woman now and I got through it and it
and it did it made a difference
so I I'm I'm very fortunate that some I
picked the right one things
so when I was in Hong Kong my one thing
was well getting out of here was my
thing getting out of here and just
trying something different I'm on the
wrong path so in that case it was a
change so I'm on the path out there what
one thing well love love in my life I'm
fit I but there's no connection there's
no woman in my life I want love in my
life another one thing uh helping people
connecting help a hundred thousand
people with my writing I wrote that down
and I've done that and then some with my
books and my blogs so I would say to to
achieve things you got to know what
you're trying to do otherwise you just
get the default of whatever's coming out
of your phone screen at you and that you
end up kind of working towards all these
um thin desires but if you can work
towards a thick desire connection with a
child love in your life or or even now
you know frankly my one of one of my
things I'm working on is is just getting
myself aerobically fit again and and I I
was and you talk about the minimalist
I'm not a minimalist but what I am doing
is I've made a decision to not add any
commitments to my life to to continue to
have the space to try and become an
athlete again
and because it's tempting to like take
little commitments and and they're all
really attractive but you have to kind
of say no and and pair them away so that
those when you're doing when you got
your five days of training you can still
meet your obligations
to your work colleagues and your and
your family but you also have enough
space to get your exercise done yeah one
of the big kind of driving principles in
all of this that tracks all the way back
to Molina that I think is is is so
instructive and and perhaps helpful for
people is this idea of the Thousand day
plan right so talk a little bit about
that because it plays right into this
thing that I love to talk about which is
that most people over index on what they
think they can do in a year and
completely you know miss the miss the
boat when it comes to what they could
accomplish in a decade and by casting
your glance you know much further down
the line and making life decisions
around that provides you the capacity
and the space to actually achieve that
thing that continues to elude you
despite you know making it a New Year's
resolution year after year
so it's January 2001.
Scott Molina
and I are riding up
Evans towards Evans pass in Christchurch
and he just he he just leans over and he
says to me
how long are you going to give this
thing
because he he's agreed to take me on as
a athlete
you know former world champion Iron Man
Hawaii Champion I mean it's a real
opportunity for me and it's deeper than
that though he's um I didn't realize I
didn't I didn't know how great he was as
an athlete he was actually a little out
of shape at the time so really he was
getting into shape training with me
mentoring me teaching me
and you know I live 5K from his house I
just turn up his garage and we go ride
for five hours and shoot the breeze
sometimes so he says you know how long
are you gonna give it I was like I I was
honest I was like I mean I don't know I
mean I I'm not sure and he's like well
before you make any decision I want you
to give it three years
so that's where the Thousand Days Came
From You Gotta Give it and he just said
you got to give it three years just to
see
where it takes you
so the three years so you know like a
year like a year and a half well two
years in I went Ultraman so I get the
positive feedback but he's right you
know I'm still only just beginning it
was another two years after that until I
had my absolute best performance in
Canada
and so it worked and and I pay attention
to things that work and and so that is
so I brought that into my coaching and
it were great with athletes people that
are trying to qualify for Kona and I
brought it into my life and I'm bringing
it back too as I was like well
you know I get back on Twitter and I
start looking around and you know you're
the reason I got back on Twitter right
do you know that no I didn't know well I
kind of told you well well yeah but we
don't have to talk about that we should
we should talk about it because if you
want to free yourself from something you
might have to talk about it at some
stage right okay so
so I'm I'm watching rich
okay you're getting you're getting more
and the ball's rolling with the Pod with
the books and everything you do is
aesthetically beautiful I mean I look at
it and it's it's not just you on on the
cover it's it's it's the cookbook it's I
mean I look at it and it just makes me
feel I was like oh it's just so
beautiful it's Beauty it really is it's
art
and I'm looking at it and then and then
as well you know there's in in me and
certainly in the people I know and and
definitely in my kids we all have this
uh desire to be um liked and a desire
for approval and so your snowball is
rolling and I'm just watching it Go
bigger and bigger and there's this
feeling of envy and and envy is
something we don't talk about much as a
society and I read this book called
wanting by Luke
and he talks about your Envy tells you
there's information there and you really
need to pay attention to it and so I I
acknowledge it and I don't just
acknowledge I acknowledge it publicly
and I and I say wow I just got this
feeling of of Envy but really what what
does it mean it's not about it's not
about it's never about what it's about
it's not about your success it's about
this calling it's about this need to
connect this need to share my message
with people and I was like you know what
I'm going to embrace it but I'm gonna do
it right I'm gonna do it on a thousand
day time Horizon so I'm going to come
back to Twitter
and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna try
and pump out some good content every
single day for a thousand days and just
see what happens I'm at day 150. I got
8.50 to go yeah
so I'm doing the Twitter thing and then
you know the yo and sure enough Johann
tweet rolls in
you know we start dming there's all this
stuff starts happening around me and I
was like wow this is there's something
going on here and I'm like you know what
this is it I've said I'm gonna go for a
thousand days I know I can shut it down
and kind of disappear again after it but
I'm gonna ride this I'm Gonna Ride This
Out for a thousand days and just see
where it takes me and so that's it I got
my I got my again just like training
where you have your basic week I got my
basic week on Twitter I do this kind of
similar things every day and I'm just
gonna roll it forward and just see where
it takes me and one of the neat things
is I was less than 100 days in and I
already got everything I wanted out of
the whole process for me personally so
you so now you're moving forward with
just this curiosity and this sense of
well I've kind of won I mean I I really
just wanted
I mean what do you need to have a great
life I mean you probably need like you
need a few people to love you a few few
people to serve I got that with my my
family and then you know a few dozen
people on Twitter that you can interact
with and have fun with it's great yeah
and it gives you that opportunity to to
express yourself creatively artistically
and to do it in service like you're
giving back like you had you're sitting
on top of all this wisdom and experience
and there is such a you know a desire
for personal growth if you're if you
have curated your social media media
feeds properly like people want the
truth right and there's a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there and people trying to
sell you their course or whatever
um but I think people have developed
much more finely tuned radar or antennae
for that [ __ ] which makes it easier
for the people who are you know
genuinely coming from a heartfelt place
to rise to the surface I mean I'm
looking around your office and I see
there's Chief magnus's book over there
and there's Brad
stillberg's book you know over there
like you know it's like these are the
people who are like you know doing it
for the right reasons who have a lot of
value and experience to share and now
you're part of that ecosystem in my life
and you know that's what brought us
together today
and that's
that's yes and that is a honorable way
to live
but there's another side of me and
there's another side of all of us
that has uh Dark Energy yeah there's a
dark side the the the drive to be
recognized and valued and in in a public
in a public way that's not necessarily
dark I I consider that innate that's
that's like a human uh human thing I
think that what I'm
let's talk about addiction
you know and
I I had a tough time last year and uh so
sometimes
if you know yourself
and you can give yourself something to
do
you can replace dark Thoughts with other
thoughts and you can but ultimately
you're just your your compartmentalizing
or just running away from that thing
that that really demands your redress
well maybe
but maybe the darkness is coming because
you haven't given yourself something
positive to do
so maybe your dedication to whatever
you're dedicated to
was a good thing at the start your
family your children being a provider
but you take it too far
and you're doing too much and you
haven't you're not
um you're not connecting to your Source
you're not connecting to what keeps you
energized you're just trying to do what
you think is right
and it leads you to a dark place and you
start thinking you don't start thinking
as well as you used to so you got to
re-energize yourself you gotta you gotta
get to your place power
at Point Break surfing's the source you
know for me exercise is a source you
know that's it it's it's riding my bike
uphill or walking through a forest
or holding hands with my wife
beside looking at the water I I mean
whatever whatever it is we each have a
source and you got to stay in touch with
that and if you can share that with
other people
you know some of these we we all have
these these kind of dark thoughts and
faulty thinking whenever when you when
you're in a good place from a mental
health point of view they just come and
go they just it's just an idea
and it just comes and goes it doesn't
become an obsession it's not a it's not
a big deal and so a lot of I needed to
connect I needed to break that negative
cycle
and you know this this return to writing
and engagement does it
so and and you know if if somebody's
listening and they're having a they're
having a tough time you know like I I
left Hong Kong you know I knew I needed
to change I didn't know what I was going
to do I had to leave I I would say you
know sometimes you gotta just you gotta
I mean the first step before you can
transcend addiction is to replace it
you have to replace it with something
that's maybe a little bit more positive
and from that point of positivity you
can work
then you can kind of work on it and
that's um you know because all I did
with my exercise was replace it and then
I just I mean I took it to the point
where I got sick from doing too much of
it and I kind of had to back off and and
then I kind of came to terms with it and
I came to a better spot with that
but you know until you and it was the
same deal with work I was I was working
all the time and and I and and I um with
my drinking I say that I've got two ways
I drink progressively more or not at all
and and so I was just like you know what
I I got kids best thing I can do for my
kids is just stop
and a few years ago and and that was it
and that and you know that just comes to
my feeling like I need to have integrity
when we sit down and we have talks about
addiction alcohol and drugs and stuff
and I'd be like yeah you could you could
do that and at some point you'll be an
adult it'll be your choice you're not
going to get in trouble but you gotta
you're gonna have to make a choice about
how you want to live your life I mean
you know they've had these childhoods
where they were doing stuff all the time
and I would hope that they would stay
engaged and continue to do stuff and so
it's really living that example for the
kids
um is is my Approach yeah well I I you
know I really appreciate the honesty
with all of that I mean obviously that's
a reflection of the inner work that
you've done to have that kind of clarity
on that
um I think it's easy for for a lot of
endurance athletes to shirk off the
addiction question but if you're doing
Ultra endurance and you're so down the
rabbit hole like you have gone and I you
know I've flirted with like you have to
you have to be you have to be somebody
who is you know prone to that level of
obsessive compulsive Behavior
or you know straight up addiction and
you know I have this history with
alcoholism to be sure there is you know
some connectivity between that and like
my love for the world of endurance and I
can dismiss it and say well that made my
life better and the alcohol made it
worse so these things are not the same
but of course they are you know if
you're being honest so I like the way
that you describe it as
replacing one for the other but still it
being a step on the journey towards
transcending it because we're learning
as we're going right and we get better
and then we slip and we find ourselves
using something else to distract
ourselves from our own pain or what have
you and like this is just life man you
know and we wake up and we try to do a
little bit better the next day yeah I
think we
I think you just you own the way own the
Way You Are
limit the damage
try and be kind
of you know I think the
as a coach
I have a I have a friend in town that's
very
um very high level running coach
and very good with
athletes that have eating disorders and
he says one of the greatest gifts
you can bring to an athlete as a coach
is to Give Them Enough self-confidence
that they can step out of sport out of
competition but also out of the
compulsion so they get enough confidence
in themselves through that athletic
journey and they get this new vision
that I experienced in Ultraman and
ultimately that strength is what enables
you to step out of the compulsion uh to
train
as well as we age we change
and our neurochemistry changes and Men
particularly we're going to become a lot
less aggressive it's also why I would
really caution people about
supplementing with testosterone and that
you don't necessarily want to give
yourself the chemistry of a 19 year old
again you want to let that aging process
play out for you because it's it can be
very beneficial to your life to to do
that and to let you fully engage in your
family and ultimately become the leader
and the Elder that your family is going
to need you to be later in life and and
develop and and I think that'll be part
of the the Transcendence
um but personally I'm I'm thinking you
know maybe not yet in in the sense that
I'm I'm not quite ready to to step all
the way out I I would really like to get
some Fitness back and share some of that
with my son or the young man my son will
become I I think I'd find that very
rewarding and I think I could offer
something to him maybe I'm reading
between the lines here but I do get this
sense that part of the challenge for you
or what you're kind of grappling with is
how do you how do you kind of quote
unquote like coach your kids and parent
your child your children but do it in a
way where you're you can have some level
of healthy Detachment from the results
of that right like if you're so caught
up in like what your kids are doing the
path the path that they're pursuing that
can be you know and as unhealthy an
obsession as anything else yeah so you
just touched on it if you don't deal
with it in yourself you're passing it
right down the family tree
and that's what happens in this town
that's why I don't go to swim meets the
vibe sometimes there is is really
intense for me
so yeah you know you just you you pass I
mean it's it's a dictionary system
epigenetics you just you pass that
behavioral pattern right down through
the kids
um yeah the reality though with Elite
and super Elite Performance is it's not
your decision as the parent the path is
so difficult there's so much work
required that ultimately it'll be
you'll have to pass the basically pass
the child off to the adult they will
become and then it's up to them and
that's something I talk about with
parents is it's not going to be your
decision you can't make this happen uh
you can prevent it from happening you
can make mistakes
the other thing is I would say work on
yourself you know get get yourself worth
tied up in yourself rather than in your
kids yeah uh you know bring honor to
your family through the way you're
acting under the roof when nobody's
looking I mean that's that's kind of
what I'm all about because I I this
whole Integrity thing I couldn't go out
and be a hero athlete and and have these
age group victories and know that my
wife was at home with a bunch of
toddlers really struggling I mean that
just for me that that sort of didn't
work and I think that's that's probably
something well that's a lot of a lot of
top athletes have to Grapple with at
some point and I would encourage the
athletes to turn towards the kids
because if you don't you're very likely
because I've seen it at the other end
you're very likely to have some lifelong
regrets but if you turn towards the kids
and things don't work out in your heart
you'll know that you had done the right
thing right for those kids when they
were kids yeah yeah that's well put
um I want to Pivot back to the big
speech that you never got to make
I don't know how much of uh those themes
that we've hit on but I want to return
to this idea of of latent potential you
know your story is so powerful in that
you were able to unlock this capacity
that
you didn't know existed but you had a
tickle in the back of your soul that was
telling you to move in a certain
direction so
that was expressed athletically in your
life it can be you know directed in
any number of you know millions of
different ways depending upon who you
are but you know on the theme of like
the speech that you want to make like
what is it you know how can we continue
that thread on unlocking that you know
the potential that we all that we all
have well what's your tickle
what's I mean what's tickling
so so you out there that's listening to
Rich and me
do you know your tickle do you do you
know what it is do you are you listening
are you able to get in contact with that
part of your mind with wherever with
whatever
um
The Muse with wherever that comes from
are you able to get in touch with that
now here's a way to get in touch with it
you can get yourself a copy of the
artist's way by Julia Cameron you can do
the morning Pages you can you can
diarize or do you still do it well
actually so
in 2000 I wrote 10 things I did the
process it's so it's it's like daily
Pages you just you just write three
pages of whatever comes to your mind
every morning say for a month then you
when you just do it no judgment
then you go back and you read it you
look for your themes and you just put
together a top 10 list okay and I wrote
I wrote uh I wrote 10 things down on a
piece of paper
um
and I got them all done in five years
and some of them seemed way out there
like you know and uh like what
big like Cheshire or grin so I I have to
ask uh you know I had no experience
writing I I wanted to touch 100 000
people with my writing
I wanted I wanted to and more than that
I wanted to help a hundred thousand
people and I don't know where it came
from and that was my goal and I mean I I
don't know I think I think we sold 50
000 copies of the book or something so
you know that was half of it and the
rest was you know you get your IP stats
on your on your blog and that love in my
life I was really hurt from that whole
process of the divorce if I if I read my
writing at the time I could see the pain
I was very
anti-marriage but when I met Monica
I knew that if I let her go it'd be the
biggest mistake of my life that's how I
knew we had to get I mean it was like we
have to get married like I this is you
know it's I don't know it's just I it
was just that was it yeah and that
feeling and and I accepted the feeling
it was the right it was I feel so lucky
that it kind of worked out uh for us and
and we're different but we're also you
know we got that the the way we live as
active people and our values are a good
fit even though we're very different in
terms of approach
so I would say you know just get
yourself a top 10 list you know just
write down 10 things you want to get
done look at it every day change it
work work on it and if you don't know
that top 10 list just keep doing the
morning pages
yeah and and listen like listen to
what you want to do and I would say you
know in the top 10 list there could be
some Thin
there could be some Thin desires I mean
not every like one of them is just ride
up Independence go down the other side
and ride back up Independence it's a big
climb it tops out about 12 000 feet so
it's just something you know it just
kind of it just kind of came to me uh
some of them some of them are pretty
deeper I I mean you know I've got a I've
got a friend that just retired from the
Navy
and I got another friend who's a doctor
and
when they listened to me
I really feel heard
and I was like you know what if I could
listen
just a bit like those guys can listen it
would really change my my life it would
be one of those transformative skills so
that's that's one of my things and
another one of my things is just get fit
and Expedition with my son
so I mean you you've got to let yourself
know
even if it seems impossible I guess it's
kind of like acknowledging maybe where
you want to go
and you'd be surprised your brain does a
good job of taking you there at least
mine does uh with with these things and
and it's fun to have a project that
you're working on yeah I mean I think
the issue that that a lot of people run
into is
just starting to create that connection
with self that you know has been
shunted for too long because we're
living our lives and we're on a certain
path or a certain direction and we don't
have time or bandwidth to really
entertain the Muse right and so to sit
down and create a practice out of
engaging with your unconscious impulses
is really powerful so if you feel like I
don't know you know everybody talks
about chasing their passion and I don't
know what my passion is well to start
writing and then like you said you
review these pages and you will start to
see recurring themes and I think when
you see things that recur it's a cue to
pay attention and to maybe say okay why
is this recurring let me go a little bit
deeper into this and then it's the
simple things like you know maybe it's
just some stupid thing that you kind of
always wanted to do that's easy to do
like honoring that right and the more
energy that you give to those things
they then you know lead you in a certain
direction like another brick gets laid
and I think the problem is most people
get caught up in wanting to know the
destination like when you said you know
I just can't show up at this office
anymore in Hong Kong I need to do
something else
it wasn't because you had a vision of of
crossing the Finish Line at Ultraman you
just had a gut feeling that you needed
to be outdoors or doing something else
right you don't get to see too many
steps down the path and I think that's
where a lot of people get caught up
because they can't see that destination
they're then too afraid to indulge the
impulse
easy
exercise light exercise
walking meditation cycling
if they're an athlete from your
background it'll be touching the water
easy it'll get you back in your body the
issue I had in Hong Kong was I wasn't in
myself in the sense
that there was all this stress and noise
and cars and like all that kind of City
stuff
I needed to get kind of into myself and
and what I mean is it's it's a it's this
concept of a maybe an integrated self or
even just you know and that's that's
where exercise is great it peels it away
I think part of that for a lot of people
extreme exercise
dangerous exercise I was a mountaineer
before
is it gets you to that state of
emptiness so when you're on a climb and
if you make a mistake you're gonna die
your mind goes empty and there is this
Stillness and quietness that you
experience that you don't experience at
a desk in Hong Kong
and the Stillness you can you can you
can misinterpret it so that you're
attracted to the Stillness you're not
attracted to the danger I think a lot of
people misinterpret it the same so in
the altar Community you're you think
it's the fatigue that is the necessary
ingredient but it's not it's the letting
go and the Stillness that that is what
you're you're feeling and and it can it
can mislead you and so you keep going
back to the to the danger if it's if
your Pursuit is a climber or the free
solo but but you know this your goals
are available right now
the Stillness is available right now if
you can if you can figure out a way to
tap into it and you tap into it by kind
of peeling all this other stuff away all
these all these desires and this noise
and it's some it's it's a meditative
practice for many for me it's always
been exercise outside particularly with
trees around me I don't know what the
deal is when I'm around trees I'm
totally chilled out and maybe that's
growing up in Vancouver you know it was
like there's like rain and water and
trees but that's what it's about so I
would say to people you know get in
touch figure out figure out what that is
and you know whatever that natural
source is and I think you'll find you if
you if you give yourself that you know a
little bit of it every day and it might
just be like just walking around the
block out of the you know getting away
from your desk or something sometimes I
just walk up the street and have a look
at the flat irons and then you know come
on come on back down just for a bit of a
reset
and get in touch with that there is a I
detect a strain of of Buddhism in that
perspective is that accurate and then
I'm as you're telling that I'm
remembering maybe my memory is failing
me but did you not like study Buddhism
did you do it a tenure at naropa like or
am I imagining that no well actually
it's a
new Indonesian beauty queen called uh
Sita and
um when I was in Hong Kong
and she the teachings of Buddha she you
know one day she just gave me that book
and she said
you know here you go and that's it she
gave me the book and and that was kind
of my introduction to Buddhism
and um and then I read it
and then you know like I said with the
whole neurochemistry and kind of getting
open up you know it opens opens your
mind up the exercise and stuff and then
I that that was like a seed and then I
then I studied a lot of Asian philosophy
and so it you know it just kind of grows
on you I mean Buddhism is really just
common sense though I I would say I
didn't formally study at naropa but I've
done a lot of reading of the different
Traditions
um all the major traditions
there's a part of me though that's a
very old testament yeah uh Very Old
Testament uh so so it's um you know my
need for
Revenge uh
the base or Gordo it's at Bay held at
Bay it's there I mean these these
ancient Traditions are like built on who
we are and I mean that's you can learn
something from all of them so I I you
know I feel and and also I I like a lot
of rules so Judaism I mean kind of
appeals to me the code uh I you know I I
really relate to that right well I think
you know the the codification appeals to
your you know kind of numbers brain like
sense of structure yeah like so much of
the way that you think about you know
living a principled life is is drilling
down to you know kind of like these
enumerated tools that reminds me of um
who's the Farnam Street guy uh Shane
yeah so it's like I had him on the
podcast and I made a joke with him I was
like you're you're a you're a computer
programmer you're trying to you're
literally trying to come up with a
coding language for human being Behavior
you know and I I see you know a strain
of that sensibility in in the way that
you think about these things as well you
know
so kids have been great in the sense of
trying to take things a little less
seriously
first website that was ever built for me
the webmaster she put a quote on it you
know don't take life so seriously
nobody's gonna make it out alive that
was on the front page
way back 20 years ago and
um I do take I do take things seriously
and and I take things too seriously and
and my friends that operate in the in
the real world I have some friends that
are really good at getting along with
everybody
and that's a skill and we need people
like that
um you know so we need we need folks
that are like you know um into duty
and service and honor but we also need
other people that are a little more
relaxed and able to kind of forgive the
you know the wisdom of forgiveness I
yeah that's that's something I could
definitely do better at
so
I want to kind of end this by bringing
it back to the walk you know like I
think
you know the fact that this whole
journey begins with a walk for you is a
really powerful metaphor like if anybody
takes anything away from this it's that
if you have an Impulse to do this thing
that's sort of orthogonal to the way
that you've been living that that's
something that you should pay attention
to and and honor so maybe you know like
let's end this with some principal
thoughts around you know honoring
yourself on this journey towards towards
that greater kind of self-integration
and and authenticity because when I look
at you it's like everything you've done
is to be just more of who you are and
like honoring that along the way and
enduring self-imposed hardship on some
level in order to kind of bring that to
the surface
yeah
well
we like things to be difficult
I read your book
I connect with that
most my friends are that way too
um my wife's a bit like that
I see it with some of my kids
so some some folks like it uh to be
difficult so you need to so if you can
see that in yourself if you happen to be
wired that way you have to there's a
couple things uh I would say be careful
about hurting yourself because you like
it to be difficult you don't need a you
don't need to hurt yourself you can
challenge yourself without hurting
yourself and you can challenge yourself
without hurting other people
so that's that's that personality strain
but when I went for that walk I was not
that man
I was I didn't have that capability that
was something that I built up over time
how did I build that up over time
the number one thing
that I would hope
somebody that wants to make a change I
would say first off stay in the game
stay with us
you help
the world you help the community by
staying with us
don't check out stay
the next thing
always stay the next thing I would say
to that
individual is make a small
promise
to yourself
might be a walk
it might just be waking up before noon
it's a small promise and you're going to
start really small
and it's going to seem tiny and all you
got to do is keep that small promise to
yourself and every positive change in my
life
has built
from the ability to keep a small promise
to myself
and this skill has extended to some very
difficult challenges
and it grows on itself over time it's a
skill it's it's a it's a strength and
you can build out from that in your life
but you have to change starts small and
it's a daily habit of doing the small
thing
to start the day and you turn yourself
into a winner by having a small win
every day and that's how it happens
yeah and those small wins when they
accumulate create a momentum that then
takes on its own energy
human beings are not capable of
understanding compounding yeah that's
the number one lesson says the finance
guy trust me
I'm I'm professionally trained
I've spent my whole life working
around money and with Investments and I
still get it wrong I still underestimate
the power of the thousand days I would
really encourage people to start small
stick with it and it's going to change
your life it really will
I think that's a good place to put a pin
on it for now but hopefully to be
continued because this was magical and I
love talking to you I'd love to have you
back on and explore some of this stuff
more deeply I think you have a gift uh
for helping people and for communicating
your experience I hope that that at some
point you'll consider writing another
book I think you've got a great book
inside you and it's just been great to
see you kind of resurface on the
internet and and and how that kind of
like brought us together finally you
know you're somebody I've wanted to meet
for a long time and I and I say this
like with all of my heart you've been
like so helpful and instrumental in kind
of guiding me from afar and I just I
really appreciate that and just wanted
to thank you for for that and for being
so open today
thank you yeah Gordo's easy to find on
Twitter at Gordo is it Gordo burn one no
score to burn what is it well field to
feed the bird no I got it I gotta say it
that's the website so my kids my well
the blog is yeah it's a it's a WordPress
blog how about feel the burn feel the
burn but it's but burn everybody always
says my yeah everybody knows everybody
says my name wrong and then Bernie
Bernie comes out he's very popular in
Boulder Field of burn was the slogan so
somehow my kids got on field to burn so
when they go to their swim meets it's
like yeah people are gonna be feeling
the burn today like we're gonna we're
gonna be racing so it's feel the burn
with a Y but on Twitter I'm feel the
burn one there you go so all right man
thanks buddy
peace
[Music]